Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Schon gehört? Der Kurz ist zurückgetreten.
Ach schon wieder.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer 414 vom2. Dezember 2021.
Ja, was soll man euch sagen? Ähm ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß gar nicht, was soll man sagen. Ich hätte es fast
hätte jetzt fast was gesagt wie Zeitenwandel steht an irgendwie Umbrüche passieren, neue Regierungen und so aber irgendwie,
Glaube in Anbetracht der vierten Welle und der allgemeinen Tatenlosigkeit, dass irgendjemand bereit ist irgendwas anzupacken. Ja, habe mich noch nicht so vollständig erfüllt.
Also das das werden wir ja sehen. Ich äh ähm bin jetzt auch mal gespannt. Ich also.
Omikron. Ich habe ja eine eine ähm,
Hoffnung, dass Ulrich Krohn quasi das Ende der Pandemie ist, weil Omi Kron klingt halt so ein bisschen nett, ne? Wie so eine alte Mutti ausm Ruhrgebiet, ne. Das ist das Omi Omi Krohn.
Oh mit Krone hat gesagt, das war's jetzt.
Genau, nee, aber ohne Mikro ist so ein bisschen nett, ne. Die macht dann so ähm.
Die die die äh äh ähm es ist sehr ansteckend aber nicht so tödlich, ne und die seucht dann einmal ganz schnell durch und dann hat sich das auch mit Omikrohn.
Du weißt, dass Alphabet endet mit Omega.
Ja, das ist das große O. Ja, das das äh finde ich ja auch sehr schön. Deswegen gibt's ja jetzt auch nur eine kleine Notbremse, weil das kleine.
Du bist so die Anstrengung Sparen fürs große O. Fürs Omega hm.
Ja. Na ja um die Kronen. Ich ich ich glaube die ist ganz nett und äh die klärt das. Die klettert jetzt irgendwie für uns alle.
Ja, jetzt haben wir eine Woche äh eine Pause gehabt, weil ich war unterwegs.
Und ähm in der letzten Folge hatten wir so ein bisschen das Spezialgefühl als wir unsere beiden Gäste am Start hatten und über die Projekte gesprochen haben.
Und äh dabei haben wir ganz vergessen über unseren HTTP-Status zu reden.
413.
Guten Tag, wir sind von Loch Buchnetzpolitik, wir möchten über ihren HTDP-Status reden.
Ist auch ein bisschen langweilig, muss ich sagen,
Also es ist jetzt so eine Durststrecke bis wieder die lustigen Sachen kommen.
Ja, bis But Gate Way dauert's noch ein bisschen, ne?
Aber aber es ist irgendwie es ist äh vielleicht ist es ja auch schön für euch. Über so was zu reden. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an die alten Chaos-Radiozeiten, wo wir dann irgendwie so,
Auch mal vorstellen, so neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig sechsundneunzig
zu so einem Zeitpunkt wo wo einfach dieses ganze Computerthema noch einfach überhaupt null Mainstream ist und wir eigentlich die ganze Zeit immer nur so in drei Buchstaben Abkürzungen Dinge von uns gegeben haben.
Totale Zumutung muss das gewesen sein. Aber irgendwie hatten wir Spaß dabei,
Jetzt reden wir jetzt reden wir hier eigentlich nicht äh so über Politik sondern jetzt reden wir halt über über Statuscodes. Das ist schon wirklich auch irgendwie so ein bisschen absurd. Aber man kann immer was dabei lernen. Zum Beispiel Statuscode vierhundertdreizehn. Das erzählt einem der Server.
Wenn die Playload to large ist, wie es so schön heißt und Payload finde ich ist auch so ein so ein wie würdest du das übersetzen?
Die die Fracht, die Lieferung, das Lieferobjekt.
Ja
Ne
Manchmal finde ich halt einfach die englischen Begriffe so furchtbar treffend und man man man es fällt einem gar nicht so richtig ein Begriff ein, der das so schön abschneidet oder das ist vielleicht auch nur unsere Vorstellung oder meine Vorstellung davon, wie gut das angeblich abgegrenzt ist, weil wir so in dieser,
Weil wir uns sozusagen die Freiheit rausnehmen können, englische Worte einfach als Fachbegriffe zu akzeptieren.
Aber es gibt schon also die Übersetzung so Nutzlast Nutzdaten, Ladung.
Last, ja genau.
Tragkraft hat Bombenlast.
Ich würde mit.
Bombenlast. Ja Bombenbombenlast finde ich gut.
Ich würde ich würde mit Nutzlast gehen.
Nutzlast ist doch äh nutzt da ne Nutzla.
Alles das, was sozusagen nicht nicht dazu gehört. Ähm das Protokoll als solches zu sprechen, sondern eben das, was man eigentlich wirklich übertragen will. Und wenn man davon zu viel drin hat, dann gibt's so einen Fehler.
Überladend, also das quasi dein oh je, du hast dein dein TCP-Paket überladen.
Ja. Das.
Also äh im Ball im im Beispiel wäre das jetzt also ich glaube, dass
käme zum Beispiel wenn du halt ein ein Upload machst, ne, dass du irgendwie Putt oder dein oder du du machst einen Post-Reak fest und dann gibt's aber zum Beispiel Limits, wie groß die sein dürfen, ja? Also kannst du jetzt zum Beispiel definieren, wer hier,
was schicken will, darf höchstens zwei MB schicken. Und dann würdest du äh wenn du mehr als zwei MB kriegst, sagen,
mir zu groß. So weit nehmen wir hier nicht an. Dafür das haben wir definiert, dass das das ist also jetzt gerade einfach zu groß. Das kann nicht das kann nicht dementsprechend, was wir hier noch haben wollen.
Manche E-Mails, aber manchmal so machen.
Ja oder wie das auch bei Paketen von Nachbarn ist, weißt du, steht das Paketmännchen vor der Tür und hat irgendwie so einen Riesenkühlschrank. Nee, Pello to large.
Ja, genau, das stimmt.
Dreizehn und dann sagt er okay aber wir müssen auch noch die vier vierzehn machen.
Ja genau, also das das ganze Thema ist Überlast, ja? Also das ist äh geht dann gleich so weiter. Nummer 414 ist nämlich die Uri to long und da stecken irgendwie zwei schöne Aspekte drin, finde ich. Also erst mal wir kennen ja alle URLs, ne?
Uniform Resource Low Cater.
Ja genau, das ist so so der das ist so der einer der TLAs, die es dies so in die äh in die Öffentlichkeit geschafft haben so. Wenn man sagt URL, dann wissen die meisten Leute, was damit gemeint ist. Und,
Gibt ja dann noch die kleine Schwester vom vom von der URL. Das ist die Uri irgendwie. Die kennen dann wiederum keiner so richtig, aber ist halt eigentlich so der allgemeinere Begriff, ne? Also der Uni.
Resource Identity Fire, oder?
Das ist sozusagen eine URL, ist einfach nur eine Sonderform der Uri, ne? Nämlich die, die man oben im Browser eingibt und wo irgendwie auch tatsächlich eine Auswert.
Server-Adresse mit drin ist, sodass man da tatsächlich eine Verbindung herstellen kann. Während halt so eine Uri an sich erst mal ganz allgemein erst mal nur irgendwas beschreibt und eigentlich im Wesentlichen überhaupt nicht definiert ist,
Außer sie ist zu lang. Dann gibt's vierhundertvierzehn und ähm weißt meistens halt auf einen Fehler hin,
Ich fand dann hier in dieser Erklärung, die ich ausgegraben habe, äh ein paar schöne äh Beispiele, was so dazu führen kann. Zwei davon sind im Wesentlichen die Software macht äh äh Müll und und und klatscht äh immer mehr hinten dran und dann wird's irgendwann zu lang.
Und dann äh die dritte Erklärung war, wenn der Server von einem Kleid angegriffen wird, der versucht durch die Anfrage sehr langer Sicherheitslücken auszunutzen,
Weil das äh fand ich dann wieder ganz passend und das passt dann auch ganz gut zu dieser Payload, ne, so dieser Klassiker, wenn irgend ein Computer was von dir erwartet, dann schickt sie ihm einfach erstmal zu viel.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das dann irgendwie dazu führt, dass irgendwas komplett ausm Binsen geht, ist relativ hoch im Internet.
Ja und noch noch schlimmer äh nicht im Internet, aber aber äh im Internet auch sehr, sehr, sehr gerne gesehen.
Ein bisschen zu viel. War jetzt, sage ich mal, diese äh,
Sprachen, in denen Web äh Geschichten programmiert sind, ja nicht mehr so anfällig sind zum Beispiel auf Buffer Overfloores, weil die ja üblicherweise eben,
das Speichermanagement schon längst abstrahiert haben, aber äh ja, immer wieder eine schöne Sache. Zu viel.
So viel es ist, es ist meistens ein ein Problem.
Viel viel hilft viel, sagt man ja auch.
Wenn mir so einer äh eine neue Webseite, ja hier guck mal, voll geil und so mal ausprobieren. Dann lehne ich mich erstmal so äh fünf Minuten auf die Tastatur und fülle irgendein Formular mit so ein paar Kilobyte aus. Das das geht dann schon mal meistens schief. Das kann man dann gleich schon mal zurückschicken und sagen so komm, komm wieder, wenn
wenn du die Basics am Start hast.
Okay, aber in diesem Moment ist halt ist die Frage, die die Uri ist zu lang, also quasi deine.
Ja halt so ein ein Detail, ein ein spezifisches äh Detail dieser Anfrage ist zu lang und so geht's ja nicht.
Okay.
Gut, dann haben wir der Surfverkauf ist jetzt offiziell beendet, ne? Wir haben ja gesagt, der ist am 28.11. endet der, aber ich glaube, es gibt da noch so einzelne Restgrößen im Angebot.
Und ich hatte gestern noch mal mit Tickethoster telefoniert, die sind jetzt auch schon am Produzieren. Also es
könnte sein, wenn ihr da jetzt irgendwelche Größen
sucht, dass die noch mal kurzzeitig drin sind. Also lohnt sich da vielleicht nochmal zu schauen, falls ihr es jetzt versäumt habt. Ähm
könnt ihr da nochmal schauen. Ansonsten werden wir das sicherlich in ein paar Monaten äh gerne nochmal machen.
Und dann äh müsst ihr jetzt nicht enttäuscht sein. Ich habe die Chance nicht nicht fürs Leben vertan.
Genau, heute ist nicht alle Tage. Wir kommen wieder keine Frage.
Genau. So, dann haben wir Feedback. Relativ viel Feedback und äh ich wollte mal ein bisschen darauf eingehen. Ähm.
Ich habe eine E-Mail bekommen, die also tatsächlich,
Also ich habe mich schon immer gewundert, weil Leute auch immer sagen, Linus, ey diese ganzen Querdenker und so, die müssen dich doch eigentlich die ganze Zeit ähm.
Angehen oder so, ne und ähm tatsächlich kommt da eigentlich relativ wenig.
Ja und dann habe ich irgendwann aber mal festgestellt, dass Twitter, die einfach mir gar nicht anzeigt. Ja, also wenn ich dann so ausgelockt bin und mal so auf meine Tweets gehe, dann sind da schon
immer irgendwelche so Verschwörungstheoretiker, die sich irgendwie,
äh nähern oder irgendwie was weiß ich, irgendwelchen Unsinn bereden, aber äh die werden mir gar nicht angezeigt. Insofern, die können sich die Mühe auch sparen. Ich glaube, die werden auch nicht anderen angezeigt. Aber jetzt habe ich mal eine Mail bekommen.
Von jemandem ähm völlig unerheblich wer das ist äh,
dachte ich da könnten wir mal vielleicht kurz drauf eingehen, weil's doch ja vielleicht nicht so blöd ist, das an dieser Stelle mal.
Wieso zeigt wieso zeigt ihr äh Twitter die Idioten nicht an, weil die dir schon alle geblockt hast oder äh.
Nee, also ich glaube erstens, weil ich also tatsächlich, natürlich, wenn irgendjemand jetzt auffällt, dadurch, dass ich jetzt jedes,
Jetzt sage ich mal, jede Hoffnung verliere das von der Person noch irgendetwas kommt, was mich irgendwie inspiriert, dann drücke ich halt auf, ja.
Aber häufig sind das so
äh irgendwelche Accounts mit mit vielen Zahlen dahinter irgendwelche Sockenpuppen oder sonst was, ne? Und die werden wir einfach nicht angezeigt, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht habe ich irgendwo einen Haken äh Qualitätskontrolle oder so, aber das machen macht Twitter nicht. Also ich sehe auch nicht jede Replay.
Du hast so einen Haken, wo drauf steht, der glaubt glaubt er eh nicht.
Nee, ich also ich kann's dir nicht genau sagen. Es kann auch vielleicht liegt das einfach da an, dass ich hier so einen alten Twitterclient habe, der mit der API nicht zurechtkommt, aber,
Das ist also ich kann mich da auch nicht drüber beschweren. Ist völlig in Ordnung. Also so so die Gans sage ich mal so die die absolute Elite des Denkens kommt dann bei mir nicht mehr durch.
Das äh aber da komme ich auch mit zurecht, so.
Wäre es bei mir eigentlich auch ähnlich, aber ich glaube, das hat auch was mit meiner intensiven Blocking-Kultur zu tun.
Ja, Blocken mache ich ja nur, wenn gar nicht anders geht, aber äh ja. Also hier.
Freundliche Mail und da habe ich gedacht, du musst auch mal drauf antworten. Hi. Hast du eine Einschätzung,
was mögliche Nebenwirkungen der Impfung betrifft.
Denn ich habe gewaltige Zweifel, wie du dir denken kannst, ich bin kein Impfgegner, mein Vater ist ein siebzig und war Arzt. Allgemein,
orthopädische. Ist aber egal, es ist doch offensichtlich, dass sich die Geschichte wiederholt. Ähm warum,
lernen wir nicht mit den Zahlen umzugehen,
nicht inzidenz, sondern Mortalität und vor allem Todesursachen abschätzen,
denn 100 Prozent gibt's nie nirgends. Das hier ist zu,
99,9neunneun Prozent real oder die Meta-Matrix.
Es gibt Behandlungsmethoden und anderes, was Trump Joe Reagan, Tim Pool und diverse andere erfolgreichen Namen.
Die haben glaube eine ganze Menge erfolgreich genommen. Ähm die in Afrika mit denen nur 5 Prozent Geimpften haben kaum Tote.
Ich bin mir sicher, es sind die NWO von Darwos, dem Great Reset und die wollen uns versklaven, bevor der Bitcoin den Banken das Genick bricht. Also,
brechen Sie die Demokratie.
Zinseszinsinflation ich bin mir sicher, du hörst da ständig und ich hoffe du ich bin einfach bloß verrückt. Bleib gesund und viel wichtiger frei. Also,
Erstmal zu all diesen Sachen kann äh Tim im Zweifelsfall viel qualifizierter Dinge sagen.
Als ich, weil er ja mit dem Corona nicht ganz so weekly mit Pavel sich mit diesen Sachen immer sehr auseinandersetzt, ja. Ähm ich mir ist nur eine Sache aufgefallen. Ähm.
Und zwar also hattet ihr ja glaube ich auch jetzt gerade in der letzten Sendung gut behandelt, ja aber was ich sehr spannend finde ist diese Sache great reset, die wollen uns verklaven, versklaven bevor der Bitcoin den Banken das Genick bricht, ja?
Dazu mal eine kleine Anekdote lieber äh zu schreiben da. Ähm der Aktienmarkt,
ähm nimmst du den DAX oder nimmst du einen Weltindex oder sonst was? Die sind alle gerade,
auf, also oder die waren jetzt alle gerade auf historischem Hoch. Ja, also niemals,
war der deutsche Aktienindex mehr wert als jetzt bis vorletzte Woche, ja? Oder vor einem Monat ungefähr 16.000 Punkte oder was, ne,
Und wenn hier einen Reset haben will, ja, dann war der,
ziemlich genau ungefähr äh Anfang oder Mitte März 2020 als die Aktien äh Kurse so richtig in den Keller gegangen sind, ja?
Und da war dein great reset, ja und wenn du da gekauft hast zu ähm,
irgendwie sagen wir mal zu den da niedrigsten Kursen dann hast du,
heute, wenn was weiß ich, irgend so ein Weltindex nimmst, ähm,
im Bereich 90 Prozent oder 100 Prozent Gewinn. Innerhalb von etwas über einem Jahr gemacht. So das heißt also nennt sich Disaster Capitalism, ja? Große Katastrophe, alles schmiert ein.
Dann deckst du dich ein mit den günstigen Aktien und dann lasse dich halt Schrott ungefähr eins, zwei, drei, vielleicht auch fünf Jahre später, aber das den langen Atem. Also wir sind von einem great reset soweit entfernt wie wir nur können.
Gerade der Bitcoin, der den Banken ja das Genick bricht, ja, der spielt ja die der spielt ja genau die gleiche Liga. Du kannst ja im Prinzip äh dir dir das anschauen, dass dass der Bitcoin auch als eben einfach nur eine Anlageform ist.
Äh die sich eben auch dementsprechend verhält, noch ein bisschen eigene Schwankungen hat, je nachdem wie der Meister aller Pump and Dump und Kursmanipulation Elon Musk gerade twittert.
Aber äh allgemein ist das einfach auch nur ein Anlageobjekt und auch das ist äh wunderschön,
durch die Decke gegangen. Also dass hier irgendwo ein great reset stattfinden würde äh oder irgendetwas den Banken das Genick bricht, glaube ich, dass es sehr sehr ähm,
sehr sehr weit entfernt. Richtig ist, Inflation, klar, das äh hasste gerade. Die betrifft aber, wenn ich das richtig verfolgt habe,
ähm quasi also bestimmte Dinge sind sehr viel teurer geworden, Autos und sowas, ja aber das betrifft also quasi,
da so diesen Inflationswarenkorb, also wo man einfach sagt, was was kauft die Familie so im im Monat oder so was und dann nimmt man davon die durchschnittlichen Preise. Wenn ihr da jetzt mal den Auto rausnimmst,
dann ist die Inflation irgendwo so bei zwei Prozent oder sowas. Was äh natürlich trotzdem sehr hoch ist und gerade auch natürlich durch Benzinkosten und so, die gerade hoch sind. Es gibt gerade eine Inflation, ist richtig.
Das ist der Grund, warum die Aktien so hoch stehen, weil alle sagen, oh mein Gott, das Kapital wird weniger wert, da wo es geschützt ist vor der Inflation, sind die Anlagegüter, also Bitcoin, also,
also äh Index-Fonds und so weiter, ja. Noch eine Sache, die ich jetzt äh wir hatten ja hier mal zu Gast den äh Daniel Krüger.
Mit dem der Fondsmanager, der uns diese Sache erklärt hat mit dem ähm.
Mit dem äh GameStop-Aktien, ja? Ähm.
Ich sage mal so, ich habe gestern mal geguckt, ja, vom Zeit seit dem Zeitpunkt dieser Sendung.
Ist dieser Aktienfonds 90 Prozent im Wert gestiegen.
So viel zum zum great reset, so ne. Wer da sein Geld reingeworfen hat,
nach unserer Sendung, obwohl wir immer gesagt haben, mach das bloß nicht.
Müssen wir mal kurz ähm.
Äh gut kacken. Also ein Reset findet hier nicht statt.
Was äh kannst du mal vielleicht noch mal genau äh beschreiben, was du unter diesem Begriff eigentlich verstehst? Mir war der ehrlich gesagt bisher noch ein bisschen unbekannt und ich habe den eher so im Verschwörungsbereich äh.
Ja ja natürlich.
Untergebracht, aber es gibt ja tatsächlich laut Wikipedia eine Initiative von Prinz also des Weltwirtschaftsforums,
tatsächlich genau diesen Titel trägt.
Und von Prinz Charles und dem Weltwirtschaftsforums Direktor Klaus Schwab Mai 20 vorgestellt wurde.
Äh ich kenne das, also eher so also ist ja bei den meisten Verschwörungstheorien so, dass das irgendwo auch schon mal äh äh benannt wurde, aber also wenn man, wenn man dieses wenn man also ich glaube, dass die,
Theoretiker da eine etwas andere äh ein etwas anderes.
Ja ja genau, also es gibt da sozusagen auch noch die passende Verschwörungs dazu äh Verschwörungstheorie äh äh dazu, die sich aber wohl auf diesen Vorschlag,
bezogen hat, nämlich
Neuordnung der Wirtschaft et cetera so, ne? Also ist immer ein bisschen schwierig mit diesen ganzen Begriffen, weil ändert sich ja auch am laufenden Meter und es ist ja auch alles so Deutungshoheiten, die da erobert werden am laufenden Meter erstmal gar nicht mehr weiß wie man überhaupt noch irgendwas nennen soll.
Aber,
nur mal diesen Begriff ein bisschen äh schärfer zu gestalten. Es wird halt die ganze Zeit mit irgendwelchen Worten rumgeworfen und alles ist immer gleich World Scale, also es ist immer gleich total episch und äh umfasst den ganzen
Globus und am Ende ist immer relativ wenig dran.
Also schauen wir mal kurz an was das äh Word Conomic Forum sagt so,
Okay, jetzt hier mit der Krise. Corona äh Covid-19-Krise mhm,
äh machen wir hier eine Initiative, die quasi,
Zukunft formen soll von globaler
globalen Beziehungen, ja, der Richtungsweisung von den jeweiligen äh nationalen Ökonomien, den Prioritäten in den Gesellschaften.
Und wie Business-Modelle ähm gestaltet werden und wie globale,
ja was würde man sagen, globale Commons, also globale Allgemeingüter äh gemanagt werden
Ja und das ist ja tatsächlich eine äh ein ein Problem so jetzt mal unabhängig, was wir jetzt vom Word-Economic-Form oder dieser Initiative äh hält, muss man ja schon sehen, dass insbesondere, sage ich mal, die globalen Ressourcen,
ich jetzt, sagen wir mal nicht nicht ähm nach äh,
nach nach irgendwie bester äh Art und Weise geteilt und genutzt werden, ne. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie allein sich anschaut, wie über die Möglichkeit äh CO2 in die Atmosphäre zu entlassen, irgendwie
gestritten wird, ne und man dann sagt, ja äh hm tut uns leid,
Indien, China, ihr dürft jetzt nicht euer volles ökonomisches Potential entfalten, weil dann macht er ja die Atmosphäre mit kaputt äh und das haben wir jetzt die letzten äh hundert Jahre schon gemacht, deswegen dürft ihr das nicht mehr, ne? Also das diese diese Ressourcenkonflikte.
Ähm insgesamt finde ich auch hier beim World Economic Forum relativ wenig,
Vision, die hier explizit ausgedrückt ist, die uns versklaven will so.
Weil das ist ein schön schön formulierte Ziele, die klingen auch erstmal gut und das das wäre auch ganz toll, ob der ob der Titel, den sie sich dafür gewählt haben, so klug war in Anbetracht dieser ganzen,
Verschwörungslage. Ja weil natürlich das dann sofort mit irgendwie einem New World Order und so weiter zusammengebracht wird und dann wieder ein weiterer Beleg ist, ja die Eliten wollen uns irgendwie umgestalten, versklaven, ausrotten, keine Ahnung was auch immer
ja, das das ist ja so dieses permanent wiederkehrende äh Ding, womit du dann auch schnell in so antisemitischen äh Verschwörungs
Ideologien reinkommst. Und das ist halt so dieser Mischmasch und dieses Feedback, was du da bekommen hast, zeigt in dieser einen Mail einfach auch sehr schön,
wie Leute sich da einfach so drin ja im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes so drin verschwurbeln, weißt du, wie auf einmal das eine dem anderen die Tür öffnet und wirklich die
komplexesten äh Strukturen da auf einmal äh entstehen, die so einfach überhaupt,
realistisch sein können, ja, weil,
es ist einfach.
Spannend, spannend finde ich diese also,
der die Mail hat hier irgendwie so ein Betreff so im Sinne von äh die Wahrheit steckt in den Zahlen oder so und es so geht's ja auch hier los, dass gesagt hat so äh warum lernen wir nicht mit Zahlen umzugehen, ja?
Ja äh gute Frage so ne wenn also okay fangen wir mit Zahl an. Nebenwirkungen der Impfung,
Also noch einmal ist es auch so, wird ja auch immer wieder gesagt so der Impfstoff, wenn ich hier,
ja. Dieser diese Impfstoffe, die gerade gegen Covid-19 eingesetzt werden, die sind so erprobt wie nur was
Die sind erforscht wie nur etwas, ne. Die ganze Forschungscommunity guckt da gerade drauf, nirgendwo wird's wird's da einfach geimpft, ohne dass minutiös irgendwie die Nachwirkungen, Nebenwirkungen und so weiter festgehalten werden.
Was habe ich mir in meinem Leben für Impfungen reinknallen lassen, die wirklich,
keine Ahnung, ey, mach mal eine Tollwut Impfung. Viel Spaß Tim. Da kommst du dir, also die haut rein, ja, da ist irgendwie so eine Covid-Impfung gar nichts ging und ähm
Die hat dann auch, weiß nicht, also was wir uns plötzlich Gedanken machen über die Wirksamkeit von Impfstoffen, ja und irgendwie nach äh vier Monaten lässt die Wirkung aber nachher okay, das
haben wir jetzt gelernt, deswegen impfen wir uns einfach noch mal, ne? Und all diese Dinge, also kein Impfstoff ist so gut App äh erforscht, wie äh die Impfstoffe,
gegen Covid-19, weil man einfach niemals so viele Leute hatte, die diesen Impfstoff genommen haben.
Äh auf einmal so gute Forschungsmethoden hatte, um die ganzen Daten zu erfassen und so viel
Vorsicht hat walten lassen äh bei der Zulassung der Impfstoffe.
Ja und noch und vor allem, was ja auch immer so so ein so ein Mythos ist so, das sah ja zu schnell gegangen. Nee, so schnell kann's halt gehen. Ja, du hast einfach genug Kohle vor allem, ja
also es gab einfach dieses Risiko nicht, weil der Hauptgrund, warum es bisher immer lange gedauert hat, war, dass das Risiko einfach zu groß ist, so einen Prozess zu starten, weil viele, viele Jahre und am Ende kommt nix bei raus. Und in diesem Fall war es einfach von vornherein so,
äh die Politik allerorten gesagt hat, so Geld spielt keine Rolle.
Sofort an, macht alles parallel. Wir helfen euch.
Pipapo und auf einmal kann so was halt auch sehr schnell gehen.
Du hast ja, du hast ja also du musst halt noch dazu sagen, es gibt ja diese verschiedenen,
Phasen in der Erprobung und wo du wo du jetzt allein mal also einfaches Beispiel du musst die Wirksamkeit des Impfstoffs zeigen, ja? Und wenn du jetzt irgendwie etwas nimmst wie.
Polio, was halt eine relativ seltene
äh Krankheit ist, die die du über Jahre bekommen kannst, ne. Kannst halt du musst halt irgendwie sagen, okay, jetzt haben wir den Podiumsstoff, jetzt haben wir die Gruppe, die Kontrollgruppe, die,
geprüfte Gruppe und dann stellen wir nach Jahren fest, okay die einen haben kein Pole bekommen, also hat wahrscheinlich der Impfstoff geholfen, ja. Bei Covid-neunzehn
ist halt so schnell ansteckend. Das ist halt und und das haben auch ohnehin so viele, dass du quasi diese statistischen,
äh diese statistische Messbarkeit einfach sehr viel schneller hinbekommst als äh bei anderen Krankheiten, die jetzt potenziell äh seltener auftreten oder so, ne? Und,
ne das das heißt weil es gerade viele haben kannst du viel,
natürliche Variationen nutzen in deiner Forschung. Während wenn du jetzt sagst, keine Ahnung, wir machen Impfstoff gegen,
was weiß ich Gebärmutterhalskrebs oder irgendwie sowas, ne? Das ist halt insgesamt eine recht seltene Krankheit, ja, also im Vergleich zu jetzt einer Covid-neunzehn, die,
hochansteckend ist und so weiter. Ähm,
da wäre da da wäre die Musik mit den Zahlen, die sich der sich diese Person gerne äh widmen möchte, ne.
Und eben auch Nebenwirkungen, steht da ja Herr Katze ja alles angucken.
Ja also wirklich also Leute lasst euch einfach impfen, fertig.
Ist einfach dann ist dieser ganze dann müsst ihr euch auch gar keine Gedanken mehr über diesen Scheiß machen weil wenn alle geimpft sind dann dann reden wir auch nicht mehr über Lockdowns und Freiheitseinschränkungen und so weiter ist das Ding auch durch. Meine.
Ist auch echt schön, wie sich das jetzt also da wandelt sich ja auch finde ich ja sehr,
beobachte, dass er nur und wie sich da jetzt langsam auch so die Stimmung,
wendet, ne? Leute sagen so, pass mal auf,
haben uns jetzt lange genug von diesen Ungeimpften auf der Nase rumtanzen lassen
und haben noch deren Interessen verteidigt und waren alle der Ansicht äh keine äh Nahbenachteiligung von Ungeimpften und so,
aber langsam reicht es so, ne? Und jetzt wo wo jetzt ja schon auch die Leute sagen, würde ich wahrscheinlich auch zu tendieren, zu sagen so, hm also,
irgendwelche Lockdowns oder so was,
oder ausgehärren oder so was, mache ich nicht nochmal mit. Ich habe jetzt hier äh meine drei Shots gemacht, schön brav. So und jetzt so habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, aber Omi-Crohn ist ganz anderer Meinung, ne.
Oh Mikron.
Oh wie Kron sagt, du, du bleibst noch mal zu Hause schön, ne.
Würde sagen geht mal schön in den Club Leute. Okay relative Häufigkeiten da gab's so ein bisschen äh Feedback zu, weil ich ja ähm,
anhand von Statistiken erklärt hatte, dass äh ähm absolute Zahlen nichts äh nicht nicht so ähm.
Sinnvoll sind und mir ist dann noch ein besseres Beispiel äh eingefallen. Also nehmen wir Altersgruppen. Wenn man nun sagt,
du hast du hast eine Bevölkerung, die hat unterschiedliche Altersgruppen, dass du die in der Altersgruppe äh 60 bis siebzig sind
So viele tausend Menschen gestorben und in der Altersgruppe was weiß ich, 30 bis 40 sind so viele tausend Menschen gestorben. Die Aussage ist ohne je also das ist sind Zahlen ohne jede Aussage. Wenn du nicht weißt,
wie groß die Altersgruppen sind. Und das ist der Grund, warum du immer,
relative Häufigkeiten ähm betrachten muss. Ja, also nur noch mal als kurze Erläuterung dazu. Daraus folgert halt so, wir wissen nicht, ob es im Club gefährlicher ist als im Supermarkt,
Können darüber spekulieren
Aber die Zahlen, die da eben präsentiert wurden, sind nicht geeignet diese Frage zu beantworten. Das ist eine,
grundsätzliche, methodische Sache hat mit was sein kann oder so nix zu tun. Ja, wenn jemand Zahlen veröffentlicht, sagt er nicht, könnte sein, sondern sagt, ist.
Wenn ihr daraus die falsche äh die falsche ähm,
falschen Schluss zieht, dann ist det zu kritisieren und falsch, Punkt.
Dann hatten wir äh über Reaktanz gesprochen und du hattest mich dann nochmal zum Ignorieren gefragt und da habe ich keine so gute Antwort gegeben. Also meine nochmal zur Wiederholung, meine These ist, es gibt circa zehn Prozent,
so im Verweigerer, ja.
Kriegst du nur mit einem Glasrohr. Ne, die werden die die werden die äh die die Dinger fälschen. Äh die werden äh was weiß ich, irgendwelche Demos machen, ja. Ach ah übrigens, hast du das gesehen? In Griechenland.
Sehr geile Geschichte, ja.
Das kann ich mal kurz erzählen, die äh in Griechenland, da gab's doch irgendwelche äh Impfgegner, die dann ähm
Ärzte bestochen haben, dass sie so eine Scheinimpfung bekommen. Das heißt, sie sollten sich einfach nur Kochsalz impfen lassen und dafür dann einen Impfausweis bekommen. Durften auch bezahlen
wurden auch angestochen, haben allerdings trotzdem den Impfstoff bekommen ohne es zu wissen,
und sind dann davon äh gegangen mit einem durchaus gültigen und dann auch gerechtfertigten Impfzertifikat, mussten bloß halt für ihre Impfung zahlen und die Ärzte haben sich doppelt gefreut. Das ist ähm finde ich also ich meine ist sagen wir mal jetzt aus rein,
aus der Medizinerperspektive unsere ethischen Herangehensweise ein zweifelhaftes Vorgehen.
Ist ein Grenzbereich des hippokratischen Eids. Ja, du könntest ja also du kannst auch sehr gut argumentieren, dass du dass es besser war für den Patienten,
du ja in dessen Interesse, in dessen besten Interesse gehandelt hast, ja und du dem ja, du musst es ja Schaden von ihm abwenden.
Ich denke auch, dass es eine Argumentation gibt. Ich weiß bloß halt nicht, ob die so gerichtsfest ist. Auf jeden Fall scheint es so gelaufen zu sein und äh ich kann mir ein gewisses Schmunzeln dabei nicht verkneifen.
Äh ich kann mir auch irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass jetzt diese dass diese Ärzte ähm irgendwie dafür verurteilt werden, dass sie das gemacht haben.
Ja im Zweifelsfall haben sie halt Leute einfach.
Wollten die wollten ordentlich betrügen und ihr habt den nicht betrogen. Äh die haben euch Geld gegeben zum Betrügen. Ihr habt das Geld genommen und also das ist.
Also richtig geil wär's halt, wenn sie die Kohle noch genommen hätten und irgendwo gespendet hätten. Vielleicht haben sie's ja auch getan so, ja.
Für irgend so eine Organisation, die gegen Impfgegner arbeitet ähm.
Na ja jedenfalls Thema Reaktanznummer, also zehn Prozent Impfgegner, die werden wir nicht los. Die müssen wir mit einem Glasrohr holen,
hast aber die anderen zwanzig Prozent, ja, also die anderen zwei Drittel der Impfgegner halte ich für.
Potentiell überzeugbar,
Und da da würde ich aber gleichzeitig sagen, dass diese Menschen halt, wenn man den jetzt mit zu viel Einschränkung, Pflicht und so weiter kommt
dass man dann eben sie in die Reaktanz führt und sie quasi zu stärkeren Impfgegnern macht, als es vielleicht ihr ursprünglich,
ursprüngliches Potenzial ist. So meine These. Dann haben wir in dem Zusammenhang, also das noch mal zum Thema Reaktanz, weil einige dann meinten, ja, die Impfgegner christlich umgestimmt. Ja, stimmt, aber es sind eben auch nicht alle deihhart, ja? Und dann gibt es ähm.
Weil diese Frage mit, wenn ich unerwünschtes Verhalten weghaben möchte, dass das einfacher geht mit Ignorieren, als mit bestrafen,
und da hattest du nachgefragt und ich habe das nicht äh weil ich mit der weil du mich eigentlich, sage ich mal, einfach in meinem Monolog gestört hast, konnte ich da jetzt spontan nicht.
Was fällt mir eigentlich ein, dich in deinem Monolog zu stören.
Konnte ich spontan äh nicht antworten. So. Deswegen das noch hier noch mal die Erklärung nachgeliefert. Also die Idee geht, also das Modell geht davon aus. Äh jedes Verhalten, was du wiederholt zeigst.
Zeigst du, weil weil du dafür belohnt wurdest oder belohnt wirst. Ja und zwar in der Regel nicht jedes Mal,
sondern intermittierend. Also,
ähm immer mal wieder wirst du belohnt. Das ist das Beste, wie du ein Verhalten stabil bekommst. Also nicht jedes Mal belohnen,
sondern in immer immer größeren Abständen belohnen,
Weil du damit quasi leuchtet ja auch ein, weil du damit leerst, dass wenn du's oft genug richtig machst du vielleicht auch nur eine Belohnung kriegst. Ja, also Beispiel, Hund, ne, bleibt an der Straße stehen, weil er nicht, ne, musst du dem Hund ja beibringen. Macht er nicht von sich aus?
Und dann machst du halt erstmal gibst du dem jedes Mal Leckerli, wenn der da äh wenn er da stehen bleibt? So, dass er bis das gelernt hat, ja? Und in dem Moment, wo der jedes Mal da stehen bleibt, fängst du an, diese Belohnung immer seltener zu geben.
Bist du vielleicht einfach irgendwann den Hund gar nicht mehr belohnt und der es trotzdem macht? Ja?
Und jetzt ist die äh ist die Idee, wenn du dieses Verhalten dem Hund wieder ähm.
Also der der beste Weg ist stabil zu bekommen ist eben intermittierend, also immer seltener belohnen,
So und wenn du jetzt aber sagen würdest, du möchtest dem Hund ein Verhalten abgewöhnen, was weiß ich, der bellt, wenn Gäste kommen oder so was, ja? Äh oder nehmen wir mal das mit dem äh Stehenbleiben an der Ampel? Bester Weg, intermittieren, verstärken, dass er's lernt,
dann wäre quasi gar keine Reaktion zeigen das Beste dem Hund das wieder,
zu gewöhnen. Wenn du den jetzt jedes Mal schlägst, wenn der an der Ampel stehen bleibt, würde man jetzt intuitiv sagen, das wird ja relativ schnell sein lassen.
Weil du schläfst ihn ja. Du bestrafst ihn ja jetzt für dieses Verhalten, das Verhalten kriegt also eine negative Konsequenz. Tatsächlich würde er schneller das Verhalten einstellen, so die,
allgemeine Forschungserkenntnis und in vielen Bereichen. Weiß jetzt nicht, ob das bei spezifisch diesem Hund so ist, indem du das Verhalten vollständig ignorierst, also den auch nicht mehr lobst oder sonst was, sondern vielleicht einfach weiter vorbei gehst.
Da wird er irgendwie dann lernt, merkt er, dieses Verhalten ist irrelevant. Wenn ich das zeige,
bringt mir das nichts. Wenn du jetzt umstößt in der Bestrafung.
Setzt quasi dieser dieser Effekt ein, dass er sagt, ey Moment, das war gerade noch belohnt. Jetzt werde ich hier bestraft. Na ja, jetzt muss ich halt einfach noch mehr leiden für meine Belohnung und so wird halt quasi erklärt, dass dass du
letztendlich ein Verhalten, was unerwünscht ist, am besten ignorierst, sodass es gar keine Kontingents damit gibt und deswegen die Menschen halt sagen,
okay,
lohnt sich nicht mehr dieses Verhalten zu zeigen. Aber du wirst natürlich auch einen Effekt haben, dass sie es erstmal stärker zeigen, weil sie denken, sie müssen's nur mehr machen, um,
eine äh um eine Wahrnehmung zu bekommen. Vor dem Hintergrund kann man übrigens gerade diese ähm.
Diese nicht mehr besonders gut besuchten Querdenker Demonstrationen und Generalstreiks sehen, weil jetzt
natürlich viele darüber berichten und sagen, guck mal hier ähm auf irgendeinen Marktplatz, auf irgendeinem Dorfplatz steht eine Person im Generalstreik, irgend so eine,
ne und sagen eine Person und äh drei Gegendemonstranten ne aber das ist natürlich eigentlich falsch, weil es eine Belohnung ist für diese Person,
sie wird es wieder machen und da andere auch sehen guck mal diese Person wird dafür belohnt stehen da halt nächste Woche auf einmal zwei oder drei, ja?
Da gibt's wieder exponentielles Wachstum.
So und jetzt wäre das ganz gut hingekriegt hat Greta Thunberg. Ja? Also nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie als Kritik wahrgenommen wird, aber die ist alleine hingegangen,
hat eine enorme Aufmerksamkeit bekommen und hat hat es geschafft, dadurch eine Bewegung äh zu gründen, ne. Nur dass diese Bewegung eben gemeinhin als positiv empfunden wird.
Und nach vorne gewandt und als wünschenswert äh andere Bewegungen funktion
arbeiten aber ähnlich. Na ja insofern wär's halt das das ist quasi diese Idee hinter dem äh unerwünschtes Verhalten vollständig ignorieren, ist potenziell sogar äh,
der der bessere Weg
kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, ob das auf diese Impfgegner äh so den Bezug hat, aber mindestens diese Reichweitweite sollte man denen eigentlich auf jeden Fall verwehren, weil das ist auf jeden Fall Belohnung.
Also die mediale Berichterstattung im letzten Jahr war da auf jeden Fall nicht hilfreich.
Überhaupt nicht. Ich meine, okay, ne, man kann ja, wenn man ähm für so ein Medium arbeitet,
Bisher alle, was so ein bisschen die Zwänge äh auch sind in diesem Gewerbe, ne? Also über Dinge berichten, die viel Aufregungspotenzial hat. Das wird ja mehr belohnt. Das ist ja auch an der Stelle auch so ein Belohnungsschema, ne?
Also man müsste auch die Medien da mehr ignorieren, wenn sie versuchen irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit zu machen und dann müssen sie sich aber alle auf Twitter auch wieder drüber aufregen und gucken mal, was die wieder Schlimmes berichtet haben und so weiter und dann verstärkt sich das an der Stelle auch wieder. Aber äh
das ist schon auch,
Problem, dass dann einfach immer wieder so ja dann äh auch so über diese Fouls Balance mit so ja, guck mal, es gibt ja auch sogar Leute, die sind der Meinung, die Erde ist flach und so,
Ach wirklich, ja. Es gibt auch ich finde bestimmt auch noch jemand, der ist der Mann und die Erde besteht aus einem grünen Wackelpudding. So, wollen wir das dann wollen wir den dann auch noch einladen.
Oder wollen wir den Tod schweigen?
Ja wirklich, als ob das ist doch eine Bewegung, die Wackelpudding-Bewegung. Kann man doch nicht einfach ignorieren.
Ich äh habe da.
Aber alle werden müde, alle werden langsam müde und das ist sicherlich jetzt auch so ein bisschen der Drive hinter äh der endlich eigen sitzenden äh Impfpflicht,
ja, die natürlich dann so von der Gegenseite gleich wieder zwangsimpfen und so weiter so. Nee, wir wollen eigentlich nicht zwangsimpfen. Wir wollen uns einfach nur verpflichtend machen.
Wir wollen nur nicht mehr, dass sie in unsere Kneipen kommt.
Ja, dass dass ihr dann irgendwie dafür bezahlen müsst, dass dass wir dann auch die Kohle haben irgendwie den Kneipen dann irgendwie die Ausfallsgelder zu zahlen so. Das zahlt ihr nämlich dann jetzt. So.
Und.
Muss den Witz jetzt hier auch nochmal bringen, weil ich glaube, hier haben wir ihn noch nicht gebracht. Ich habe ihn jetzt auch schon selber tausend Mal um die Ohren geworfen, ne, so dieses ein Euro am ersten Tag. Zwei Euro am zweiten Tag.
Und so weiter, damit ihr auch mal wisst, was exponentielles Wachstum ist. Das wäre die richtige Strafe sozusagen, finde ich, impfen.
Du weißt, ich bleibe dabei, ich ich wiederhole meine Forderung am Impfzentrum 100 D-Mark-Begrüßungsgeld.
Ja, ja ich habe.
Ich bin für Begrüßungsgeld. Das ist das ist es einfach. Positiver Anreiz. Das kennen die auch, ja. Grade in Sachsen so. Na okay,
wieder Ärger. Ich habe übrigens hier zum Thema äh wen man zu medialer äh Aufmerksamkeit verhilft und wem nicht ein äh Blogpost vor kurzem geschrieben. Ähm da wurde ich nämlich zu einem Streitgespräch eingeladen und,
dann freundlich ähm abgesagt, dass ich dass ich nur über Dinge streite, die strittig sind und nicht bereit bin.
An diesem Streitgespräch teilzunehmen, ist verlinkt in äh den Shownotes,
Äh ja Impfquote in Österreich wurde dann auch nochmal in einem Kommentar angemerkt, die wäre ja doch mehr gestiegen und nein ist sie nicht. Also ist sie nicht. Wir haben's heute Morgen noch im Deutschlandfunk äh gehört dabei irgendwie,
so ist ja mein Radiowecker äh so einer der auch sagte so ungefähr anderthalb Prozent ist die Quote der Erstimpfung angestiegen durch,
seitdem sie da jetzt die strengeren Maßnahmen, die eher Impfungen äh,
haben wollen und wenn man sich die Grafik anschaut, getrennt nach den Booster-Impfungen, ja, dann siehst du halt, die Booster gehen hoch wie Hulle,
ähm die Erstimpfungen im im Vergleich dazu wirklich äh sehr, sehr wenig. Habe da noch mal eine neue Grafik in diesem Blog.
In Österreich.
Ja in Österreich, ja.
Deutschland gehen sie hoch. Also das äh.
In Österreich ja auch, nur der Effekt ist halt nicht groß. Guck dir äh also ich ich schicke dir noch mal ganz kurz, dass du jetzt hier draufschauen kannst, die spezifische Grafik, ja äh.
Da siehst du, der obere, also die Grafik ist in meinem Blogpost. Blogpost ist in den Shownotes. Ähm da siehst du,
ne der obere der obere Bereich sind diese hellgrüne ganz oben das sind die ad least one does,
Und äh wenn du jetzt vergleichst, wie die Booster hochschießen im Vergleich zu den äh ad least one does, also Erstimpfungen quasi,
dann siehst du, dass der Effekt bei den Erstimpfungen ja als äußerst gering ist.
Vor allem wenn du jetzt mal vergleichst, was dann die was das was die Tätigkeit der Impfstationen ist, ja, die dass die halt viele Tausende jeden Tag boostern und ein paar Hundert äh jeden Tag äh Erstimpfen.
Dass es eben also der Effekt auf die Erstimpfungsquote ist ja wohl mal äh ausbaufähig.
Also kumulative Grafiken ist so eine Sache. Also.
Die da die da drüber ist, äh wo es nicht kumulativ ist.
Ich ich guck's mir grade ähm bei an. Also sie hatten schon eine äh eine Vervierfachung der Erstimpfquote, die jetzt äh wieder äh abgesunken ist. In Deutschland steigt sie gerade.
Aber guck mal, das ist genau der das ist genau der Punkt. Die Erstimpfquote war halt niedrig, ja, dann hast du die vervierfacht. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, aber du kommst trotzdem nur auf anderthalb Prozent deiner Bevölkerung.
Nee, ist klar. Also das ist nicht ausreicht, ist äh ist schon klar, aber ich denke, äh das das wird schon noch Dynamik äh entfachen. Wird man erst danach wissen.
Haben wir von Lisa eine Mail bekommen kurz vor der Sendung, die ich jetzt auch mal also die will ich jetzt einfach nur mal als Horrorstory vorlesen.
Hallo Tim, hallo Linus. Ich weiß, ihr hört ja immer gerne Storys aus deutschen Verwaltungen mit Spezialgebiet Impfausweis. Da ich kurz davor bin, meine,
Wohnung einfach bis zum Sommer nicht mehr zu verlassen, dachte ich, ich schreibe euch damit wenigstens jemand anderes sich an diesem Drama belustigen kann. Hintergrund. Ich habe aus eigener Dummheit meinen Impfausweis verloren.
Ich bin doppelt geimpft worden und das schon sehr früh. Im April in einem Impfzentrum. Da gab es noch keine QR-Codes und weil ich
dumm und unaufgeräumt bin, habe ich auch partout nicht kann ich auch partout nicht diese Zettel finden, die man,
bekommen hat im Impfzentrum. Nein, ich habe den Impfausweis nicht digitalisieren lassen. Ich weiß, dass das Dom war.
Naja, denke ich mir. Wir wohnen in Deutschland. Irgendwer wird das schon aufgeschrieben haben und kann mir einen neuen Nachweis ausstellen
Hier die chronologische Auflistung der Stelle, die ich angerufen habe, Krankenkasse,
Laden sie sich mal die Krankenkassen-App runter und gucken sie nach, ob das da drin steht. Dann kann die ja aus Harz das machen. Zugangscode schicken wir ihnen per Post zu, weil wir dürfen nicht in ihre Unterlagen,
Krankenkasse zwei, nachdem in den Unterlagen nichts zu finden war. Ach so, ja, Impfzentrum. Da haben wir dann nichts. Das ist direkt mit dem Bund verrechnet worden, sorry. Gesundheitsreferat.
Gehen Sie einfach zur Apotheke, die haben Zugang zur Datenbank und können das dann so ausstellen. Im Impfzentrum brauchen Sie nicht anrufen. Zugang zur Datenbank haben nur Apo,
und das Landesamt für Gesundheit. Apotheke. Welche Datenbank?
Trotzdem beim Innenzentrum angerufen. Ja, schicken Sie uns eine E-Mail mit Ihren Daten. Dann suchen wir das raus. Das dauert so drei bis fünf Tage. Eine Woche später wieder beim Impfzentrum angerufen. Die Kollegin guckt sofort nach. Wir schreiben gleich eine E-Mail.
E-Mail kommt, ihre Unterlagen konnten bisher nicht im Impfarchiv gefunden werden. Wir haben die Suche im Papierarchiv veranlasst
Das kann mehrere Wochen dauern. Wir melden uns bei Ihnen, sobald wir etwas erreicht haben. Landesamt für Gesundheit, ist uns eine E-Mail. Keine Ahnung, wie lange das dauern konnte. Tüdelü.
Also, niemand kann mir sagen, ob ich mal geimpft worden bin. Ich kann meinen Booster-Termin nicht wahrnehmen,
Dafür müsste ich ja nachweisen, der sich vor fünf Monaten geimpft worden bin. Niemand kann mir sagen, ob ich jetzt einmal mich einmal komplett neu impfen lassen muss, wenn man nichts in den Archiven findet.
Mal ganz zu schweigen von einem Dilemma, das ich zu einem Termin zu fahren, den ÖPNV nehmen muss, für den ich einen Test brauche. Hatte ich erwähnt, dass ich den ÖPNV nehmen muss, um zum Testzentrum zu kommen?
Wir waren nicht klar, dass ich noch weiter von der Organisation in dieser Pandemie enttäuscht werden könnte, aber hey, schlimmer geht anscheinend immer mit bestem, wenn auch leicht frustrierten Grüßen, Lisa. Ja, Lisa, tut mir sehr leid. Ich kann dir da auch nicht helfen.
Das das ähm bringt natürlich mehrere interessante Punkte auf, ne. Also erst mal, was ich natürlich jetzt hier offenbart, ist so diese totale Konfusion, ne. Äh mir noch ein bisschen fehlt hier äh oder was noch gefehlt hätte.
Ob's dieses Impfzentrum denn überhaupt noch gibt. Ja also das Problem haben ja dann auch viele Leute. Ne, weil so was kann natürlich passieren, ne? Und eigentlich ist es.
Schlecht, dass man eben so einen Nachweis nicht führen kann. Also ich finde es jetzt,
Datenschutz hin, Datenschutz her, meiner Meinung nach sollte es eine solche Registrierung dieses Impfvorgangs,
geben. So. Das sollte der Krankenkasse bekannt sein. Ähm ja, die ja,
primär oder oder wo auch immer dieser Rekord letzten Endes gespeichert wird. Ich habe jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt
keinen Überblick äh über die aktuelle Situation der Digitalisierung, des Gesundheitssystems ist es jetzt mal sagen könnte, wo eigentlich dieser Rekord so liegt und es gab ja auch die Initiative von Herrn äh Spahn im letzten
Winter schon. Ja, das ist RKI angewiesen ist eine zentrale Impfdatenbank einzurichten. Da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt seitdem,
nichts mehr von gehört, aber sowas muss halt eigentlich mal kommen. Weil sonst hast du auch einfach keinen Überblick in so einer scheiß Pandemie. Und das ist natürlich hier so ein generelles Problem, ne, dass wir auf der einen Seite immer so eine datensparsame äh einfordern vom vom Staat,
auch zurecht. Ja, nur,
Dass sich das natürlich dann auch beißt mit so organisatorischen Anforderungen. Weil du kannst dann halt auch einfach manchmal keine richtigen Entscheidungen fällen, wenn du keine guten Datengrundlage hast. Und
Das ist ein generelles Problem, was wir glaube ich auch mal in dieser Gesellschaft mal neu aushandeln müssen. Sicherlich auch in unserer.
Freiheitsorientierten Datensparsamen Szene, ja? Das das wir's hier mit einem Widerspruch haben, dass man auf der äh zu tun haben, dass wir auf der einen Seite,
Daten haben wollen, um richtige Entscheidungen fällen zu können oder auch solche Fälle abzudecken. Aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich uns auch immer bewusst sind,
was das so mit sich bringt, ne. Ähm nur mal so in einen Raum gestellt.
Also ein zentrales Impfregister wäre jetzt hier so die Sache, ne? Wer könntest du dir ja im Prinzip.
Absolut wichtig. Einfach um mal überhaupt beurteilen zu können. Ich meine, das RKI muss Telefonumfragen starten, um irgendwie rauszufinden, wie viele Leute sich wahrscheinlich tatsächlich wirklich geimpft haben. Und am Ende sind sie sich immer noch nicht so sicher.
Am Ende sagen sie, oh wir haben ja viel mehr geimpft, weil da irgendwelche Querdenker sind die, die wahrscheinlich nachher in der Telekom-Gruppe sagen so
alter Vater. Jetzt hat das RKI angerufen, ob ich geimpft bin. Die wollen mich fertigmachen. So dann dann haben sie halt irgendwie eine höhere äh eine höhere Dose eine höhere Rate da gemessen. Also.
Was ich denke ist, also es.
Ich glaube schon, dass sie irgendwie nachweisen wird, dass sie nachweisen können wird, dass sie da war und diese Impflerface bekommt. Das Blöde ist natürlich.
Glaubst du? Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Jahr jetzt die die andere Sache ist natürlich tja was würde man machen jetzt da gab's nämlich auch noch einen Kommentar der mir habe ich auch noch gerade rausgesucht weil wir ja,
Irgendjemand muss wohl äh gesagt haben in der Sendung er hätte den Booster vor Ablauf der sechs Monate bekommen, ja und da äh kommentiert Götz,
Booster vor Ablauf der sechs Monate. Ich bin Kinder- und Jugendarzt. Impfen ist unser Kerngeschäft und unsere Kernkompetenz. Ähm,
wenn eine der normalen Impfungen auch nur einen Tag früher gegeben wird als in der Fachinformation beschrieben, dann meckert unser Impfprogramm und die Impfung ist,
auch immunologisch nach SIKO und so weiter als nicht gegeben zu bewerten.
Ich sorge mich, du kommst nach fünf Monaten, wirst geimpft. Im digitalen Impfpass ist ein Algorithmus hinterlegt, der auch die Abstände der Impfungen spiegelt,
Wenn ja, dann wird euer Impfzertifikat bei den nächsten echten Kontrolle als nicht gültig angezeigt. Das wäre doch doof. Könnt ihr rauskriegen, wie der Algorithmus rechnet.
Also ganz also habe tatsächlich habe ich mir angeschaut,
In dem Impfpass ist kein Algorithmus hinterlegt, der auch die Abstimmabstände der Impfung spiegelt. Das ist eine Hypothese und kein Fakt. In meinem,
zweiten und dritten Impfzertifikat steht gar nichts von den jeweils vorgegangenen Impfungen.
Äh und in dem Zweiten auch nichts von der Ersten. Ähm also da steht einfach nur,
Es wurde erteilt Impfung drei von drei. Ja und das wäre jetzt eben auch der ähm,
Also du musst quasi den du brauchst brauchst überhaupt nicht das Impfzertifikat für die erste Impfung. Die haben die Apotheken ja nur ausgestellt weil sie damit auch noch mal Geld verdient haben. Und ähm letztendlich steht in dem Impfzertifikat so wie ich das jetzt mal dekoriert habe nur drin.
Es ist eine Impfung erfolgt mit dem und dem Stoff und das war die Dritte.
Genau. Was natürlich auch Unsinn ist, nicht, weil diese Hysterie kann ja auch immunologisch wertvoll sein. Äh ich erinnere nur an diese ganze ja, ich erinnere uns nur an die ganze Debatte mit, wie wirksam ist, welche Kombination von Impfstoff.
Kann alles sein, ne? Ich wollt's jetzt nur mal ganz kurz sagen, zweite Antwort wäre aber.
Ich würde es nicht als Strafe empfinden, wenn jetzt jemand mir meine Boosterimpfung annulliert,
lasse ich mich halt noch mal boostern. Also ich lasse mich ja für den Impfschutzboostern nicht für das Zertifikat,
also fällt's jetzt auch nicht tragisch, wenn äh wenn die sagen, wenn nein, das nicht gültig, du hast keine Dritt-Impfung also,
Die werden mir nicht sagen, du bist jetzt im Dead-End und äh du bist jetzt ungeimpft
So viel Spaß äh auf dem äh beim Suchen des Genesenenstatuses oder sowas, ja. Äh das das äh halte ich für nicht wirklich äh relevant, ja. Vor allem wie du grade auch schon sagtest
Tim, dass dass hier die die Erfassung der Daten eher nicht ausreichend ist, um solche Dinge zu tun. Aber ja, ich persönlich fände's nicht schlimm,
mir jetzt der Booster nicht anerkannt wird. Für Lisa hier in unserem Fall ist natürlich schlimm, weil ihr quasi die Zweitimpfung nicht anerkannt wird. Das heißt, ihr steht ja jetzt mindestens also sie könnte jetzt sagen, alles klar, ich fange einfach von vorne an, aber der hat's ja trotzdem nochmal Erstimpfung,
und äh ähm dann noch mal eine Zweitinfulation wie viermal geimpft und hat trotzdem nur den Status ähm.
Nur den Status äh zweifach geimpft statt äh geboostert. Also es ist auf jeden Fall schlecht und ja ähm.
Obwohl sie schon vierfach unterwegs ist. Ja, es ist.
Die bestgeimpfte Ungeimpfte. Noch besser als die Griechen.
Ähm ja also ich glaube, da muss man halt mal dranbleiben und für alle anderen bleibt es halt hoffentlich die Mahnung ähm diese Impfnachweise aufzubewahren, insbesondere auch diese Digitaldinger, die ihr da bekommen habt ähm.
Hatte ich ja auch erwähnt.
Genau, denn der Staat kann es nicht tun für euch.
Zieht nicht automatisch auf euer neues Handy mit um, wenn ihr das Handy verliert, ist das schlecht und ähm ja also die muss man gut aufbewahren.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ähm.
Eine Debatte, die wir wirklich in Zukunft haben werden und auch klug führen müssen in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang, ist natürlich, dass wir einfach über kurz oder lang unter solchen Gesichtspunkten unter solchen,
also solche universellen IDs und zentralen Speicherungen von bestimmten Informationen über Personen unumgänglich sein werden.
Man muss sich halt darüber Gedanken machen, wie man das ordnungsgemäß,
gestaltet. Ja, wie man Zugriff und Missbrauch äh ausreichend verhindert, aber wie man eben auch nutzen für den Staat sicherstellen kann. Das ist einfach ein klassischer Abwägung von Chancen und Risiken.
Und ähm da kommt man glaube ich mit Maximalforderungen auf beiden Seiten nicht sehr weit. Sondern muss eher mal überlegen, wie man das klug lösen kann, weil es ist sicherlich auch in irgendeiner Form,
lösbar. Du sagst nicht, ist einfach, Sunnah ist lösbar.
Mhm. Ja. Es mein ich finde es,
also man kommt natürlich an ich wäre jetzt nicht so Fan eines zentralen Impfregisters aber es wäre natürlich schon ganz gut wenn wenigstens die Lisa jetzt irgendwie,
Nachweis nochmal führen kann, ne? Dafür brauchst du vielleicht nicht ein.
Wäre schon Fan von so einem zentralen ich meine ich habe eine Steuer-ID,
Ja, die haben wir alle. Die kriegst du mittlerweile zur Geburt kriegst du deine deine Steuer, die diese ID existiert so und das ist ja ohnehin,
auf die sich der Staat schon eingeschlossen hat. Ich kam beim Finanzamt,
Alle Informationen nachfragen, wann ich welche Steuer wie wann wo bezahlt habe. Ja also es ist wirklich man kann wirklich sämtliche Steuerunterlagen kann man verlieren. Das Finanzamt weiß Bescheid
nicht so, dass man da anruft und sagt, ja nee, keine Ahnung, fragen Sie mal, irgendwo, rufen Sie doch mal beim Gesundheitsamt an. Vielleicht wissen die, wann sie ihre Steuern bezahlt haben. So eine Antwort wird da nicht kommen
die wissen das einfach. Die haben das gespeichert, das kann man auch abrufen,
So und so machen es halt auch viele andere Staaten, dass ihr halt einfach Bescheid wissen über diese Belange und äh der Impfbereich ist sicherlich ein Bereich, der damit äh gezogen werden
muss und es gibt auch bestimmt noch ein paar andere Bereiche, wo das ganz angemessen.
Ich bin da nicht so noch nicht so von überzeugt, aber die ganze Sache zentrale Datensammlung haben wir hier schon öfter mal diskutiert. Deswegen lass uns doch ganz schnell mal zu den gefälschten.
Ein Spannungsfeld.
Spannungsfeld. Da kann man ein Streitgespräch zu führen. Ähm
Der Handel mit gefälschten Impfpässen nimmt zu. Wer hat's angekündigt? Äh schön
Mitarbeiterin in der Apotheke hatte Kriminellen einen Zugang in die Apotheken-IT verschafft, nachts produzierten ihre Komplizen. Mehr als 1000 digitale Impfnachweise auf die echten Namen von Impfgegnern. So stimmten die Personen
da der Besteller im Ausweis mit denen auf dem digitalen Impfnachweis überein in der Apotheke wusste man von den Machenschaften nichts. 1000 Stück Preis,
dreihundertfünfzig Euro, so dreihundertfünfzigtausend Euro schwarz gemacht, ne, vielleicht hat man's auch irgendwie günstiger gemacht, so läuft der Hase. Obwohl der Fall bereits im Oktober aufflog gelang es
den Reportern noch bis Anfang vergangener Woche.
Ein digitales Zertifikat der Apotheke in die App hochzuladen und in Koffpass check,
erschien es als valide also gültig. Ja dann,
haben sie dieses eine Zertifikat den Behörden gemeldet und dann ist es auf der schwarzen Liste gelandet, aber äh wenn dann die Luxemburger App prüft, dann ist es trotzdem noch gültig, ja. Also äh,
Das ist der Punkt. Wir haben das hier auch immer wieder besprochen,
wenn du solche Dinge ausstellst, brauchst du Revocation, Revocation ist ein gelöstes Problem, wurde damals nicht in Auftrag gegeben, versuchen sie jetzt reinzuklöppeln, ist nicht einheitlich. Äh das ist ein Riesenproblem.
Und hier scheint ja wenigstens, was ich ganz gut finde, in Anführungszeichen. Die haben das ja nachts gemacht. Ja, das heißt, wenn du jetzt die Records dir anschaust, dann weißt du wenigstens, welche Impfpässe außerhalb der,
Geschäftszeiten der Apotheke erstellt wurden und kann's wenigstens sagen, die sind nicht echt.
Mhm.
Ja? Das ist ja schon mal da ist ja wenigstens ein schönes ein Marker, wo du sagen kannst, okay die ne, aber du hast natürlich ähm auch immer auch etwas klügere Leute,
als als die, ja.
Das mal so zwischendurch machen am Tag.
Ja also das das das Problem wirst du leider also und das wirst du auch nicht in den Griff kriegen mit irgendeinem zentralen Impfregister. Ja also da na ja na gut.
Dann hatte ich ja in äh in auf Twitter angekündigt, dass ich noch kurz hier meinen äh Härtetest für den für den dritten.
Noch mache. Man hat hier eine rote Warnung. War tatsächlich meine erste rote Warnung, Tim. Ich hatte noch nie eine rote Warnung in der Corona-Warne.
Wo hast du dich wieder rumgetrieben?
Äh ja, ich war auf einer also an dem Tag war ich nur an einem Ort äh äh und das war die eine Veranstaltung,
von oh ich weiß Wegweiser oder so hieß der Ausrichter und da wurde diskutiert über irgendwie rechtlich Regulierungsbedarf Straftatenverfolgung im Darknet.
Ähm da war ein Vertreter des Bundes der Kriminalbeamten, ein äh Vertreter der CDU,
eine,
Frau vom BKA wäre da gewesen, aber äh konnte nicht mehr. Also die durfte nicht wegen äh Reiseeinschränkungen Corona.
Die konnte nicht mehr.
Konnte nicht mehr. Deswegen hat und das fand ich sehr unterhaltsam ehrlich gesagt. Der Moderator dieses Panels war Andreas Köhn, der arbeitet im Innenministerium,
da fand ich jetzt so ein bisschen interessant, dass jetzt der Moderator,
Also Regulierungsbedarf Darknet moderiert vom Innenministerium und zwar genau von demjenigen, der quasi diese Gesetzesvorschläge in diesem Bereich IT-Sicherheitsgesetz ähm
äh quasi Staatstrojaner in also all diese Sachen äh ja mit federführend verantwortet von dessen Haus
die ja ausgehen, fand ich jetzt als Moderator äh,
als Personalie äh eine eine ungeeignete Wahl, hat sich aber Mühe gegeben also gegen die Moderationsleistung kann ich ja jetzt nichts sagen. Ich fand's jetzt nur von der Personalie her eine komische Auswahl. Ähm.
Und da haben wir über die ganzen äh Strafverfolgungsmöglichkeiten in diesem Bereich da gesprochen, wo wo sind die Probleme und wo sind die Erfolge? Finde ich übrigens sehr interessant, weil der Vertreter des äh,
Bundes der Kriminalbeamten,
auch gesagt hat, ja wir haben viel zu viele Daten, ja wir haben nicht zu wenige, wir haben zu viele. Ähm das äh war sehr also sage ich mal ein überraschender äh überraschende Unterstützung ja von jemandem, der diese Arbeit eben auch jeden Tag macht.
Ähm ja das war sehr äh war eigentlich eine ganz ganz,
interessante Diskussionen bei weitem nicht so schlimm, wie ich ursprünglich vermutet hatte, auch sehr angenehm und äh ja, war alles super.
Aber waren alle verseucht.
Na ja, also es war mit Maske,
und ich hatte dann am also aber auf dem Panel auch immer die Person, die gesprochen hat, hat dann für diese Zeitraum ihre Maske abgenommen, sonst aufgelassen
der heißt aber glaube ich nachher noch Mittag gegessen, das habe ich ohne Maske äh kann ich, kann ich kriege ich immer nur ohne Maske ganz gut hin und ähm
Dann hatte ich eben am nächsten Tag,
äh rote CWA-Warnung. Ja und dann habe ich mir damit einen PCR-Test äh geholt und der hat etwas länger gedauert, weil's mir lieb war.
Am nächsten Tag hattest du schon die Warnung. Die sich auf den Vortag bezog.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie das war, wie das jetzt kam. Ich kann mir jetzt auch nur vorstellen, dass vielleicht die dort ja eine Person, die dort war, vielleicht abreißend und und und es war sogar so eine Distanzwarnung, glaube ich.
Weil dann müsste die Person ja quasi an dem Tag selbst einen Test.
Wahrscheinlich noch einen PCR-Test gemacht haben, ja.
Gemacht haben, dessen Ergebnis dann am nächsten Tag an dem du gewarnt wurde, es kam und der sofort freigeschaltet wurde. Bemerkenswert.
Ja ja und da also ist bin mir relativ sicher, dass das direkt am nächsten Tag war. Kann auch ich meine echt. Muss ich auch mal auf Twitter gucken, aber ja. Dann habe ich mir ein äh konnte ich mir PCR-Test klicken und ähm.
PCR-Test gemacht hat und nicht so kostet, Ergebnis bekommen, also eins A.
Wo hast du den Test machen lassen?
Wollte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, weil ich ja nicht für irgendwelche Unternehmen hier werben möchte, aber.
Ja was? Also war's ein Unternehmen oder war es ein Testzentrum des Landesamtes? Weil ich habe immer gehört, dass es dort am wenigsten Probleme gibt bei den städtischen Einrichtungen.
Also das es war ein Unternehmen, welches auch sehr bekannt dafür ist, dass es PCR-Tests äh anbietet.
Und diese auch in zur Selbstentnahme mal verkauft hat früher und an verschiedenen Flughäfen äh mein Eindruck äh Labore unterhält.
Und die dann, mein weiteres äh mein weiterer Eindruck mit unterschiedlichen Schnelltestzentren quasi Kooperationsverträge haben. Das heißt, äh ich habe gesagt Halles hallo hier, ich möchte
PCR-Test machen. Dann hat sie gesagt warum. Habe ich gesagt, rote Warnung, Corona-Warn-App. Dann haben wir gesagt, alles klar. Und da habe ich quasi so ein Ticket bekommen, so einen QR-Code und dann ähm.
Gesagt, ich möchte zu dem und dem Schnelltestzentrum gehen. Dieses Schnelltestzentrum wurde aber überhaupt nicht von denen unterhalten, ne. Das war in Ewen ein komplett anderes Schnelltestzentrum und äh da bin ich irgendwie reinmarschiert. Da habe ich gesagt, hier PCR-Test äh ja alles klar,
äh dann würde ich jetzt vermuten, dass dann irgendwann am Abend.
Äh oder vielleicht auch erst am nächsten Morgen dort einen Transporter vorbeigefahren ist, die Probe abgeholt hat, ins Labor gefahren hat und dann haben die da die PCR gemacht und wie gesagt, die hat etwas also sie hat über 24 Stunden gedauert und dann habe ich irgendwie das das Ergebnis bekommen.
So meine so meine meine Interpretation dessen, was da stattgefunden hat.
Mhm. Sonst realistic.
Also der dritte Chip im Praxistest hat er gut gewirkt.
Mhm. Geil.
Aber dann denkst du natürlich auch wieder, ne? Gut. Mit welchen Personen war ich da wie lange zusammen? Ähm auf dem Panel Maske getragen nachher nicht.
Es könnte jetzt auch sein, ja ohne will jetzt niemanden auf dieser Veranstaltung. Es kann ja theoretisch auch sein, zeitlich käme es hin, dass das vielleicht eine Person war, die
äh in der U-Bahn auf dem Weg dorthin,
neben mir gesessen hat, ne. Das wäre jetzt theoretisch auch noch möglich, um jetzt sage ich mal, diese dass man den Status rot hinkriegt, ne.
Und wäre es denn für dich nicht ganz beruhigend, wenn du jetzt die Uhrzeit dieser Begegnung auch noch etwas eingeschränkt bekommen hättest und nicht nur den ganzen Tag.
Jein, also ich wüsste nicht, das hätte also es ich weiß, dass du das bevorzugst und es wäre sicherlich auch äh jetzt interessant gewesen, aber ich ähm.
Es hätte für meine Handlung keinen Unterschied gemacht. Ja, also ich hätte jetzt keines mich nicht anders verhalten.
Äh
wenn ich äh also abgesehen davon, wenn es jetzt hier U-Bahn oder so, das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, sie ist so genau, wann ich da war und wann ich da weg war. Ja, also wenn ich da jetzt die genaue Uhrzeit gehabt hätte, wär's auch nochmal irgendwie, wenn das jetzt nicht, sagen wir, während des Panels gewesen wäre, hätte ich jetzt gewusst, okay, aber ähm,
kenne jetzt auch nicht genau dann sagen wann und wo das war und für mein Handeln hätte es keine Konsequenz gehabt.
Ja, na gut, aber ich meine, du warst ja auch nicht positiv. Ja, dann hätte dein Handeln vielleicht ähm eine andere Konsequenz äh gehabt und theoretisch hätte das Telefon sich das ja auch schon merken können, wo das gewesen ist. Also.
Ich weiß, das fängst du auch jedes Mal an.
Ist keine große Diskussion machen. Ich sage nur, das ist so ein Aspekt, ne.
Aber wo weißt du ja, dass es sich das nicht merken kann? Weil es nicht auf GPS zugreift gleichermaßen.
Die App, ja die App, aber das Telefon könnte es ja machen.
Ja, genau. Hat hätte jetzt muss ich sagen, hätte für mich keine äh also hätte für mein Handeln keine Konsequenz. So. Ähm.
Insofern ja, mal anderes Mal hatte ein guter Freund eine, da konnten wir's auch äh quasi pin-pointen, wo das gewesen sein muss.
Wollen wir gemeinsam mit einem Restaurant, das war jetzt der einzige Ort, an dem wir uns längere Zeit aufgehalten haben. Er hatte eine rote, ich hatte eine grüne Warnung, auch lustig, weil wir gemeinsam an einem relativ kleinen Tisch saßen. Aber okay, die ganzen Unzulänglichkeiten haben wir ja jetzt hier äh
zu genüge schon behandelt.
Seid ihr auch gemeinsam aufs Klo gegangen?
Nee, aber da bist du ja nicht so lange, dass dass es reichen würde für eine rote Warnung.
Naja.
Also so viel haben wir nicht gegessen, dass man jetzt so lange.
So, kommen wir endlich zum Thema auf das alle warten, oder?
Ähm welches denn?
Koalitionsvertrag.
Echt? Warten da alle drauf.
Konstantin Kuhle von der FDP twitterte dazu, der heutige Tag ist ein Aufbruch für die Bürgerrechte. Recht auf Verschlüsselung
Schwachstellenmanagement, keine anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung, kein Staatstrojaner bei der Bundespolizei, Überwachungsgesamtrechnung
Schwachstellenmanagement nochmal Strafrecht als Ultimatisation. Ähm ja ähm,
die der die Hoffnungen, sagen wir mal, äh dass die das Vorhandensein der FDP und äh natürlich insbesondere auch der Grünen in dieser Koalition.
Im Bereich der Digitalpolitik äh verhaltenen äh Anlass für gute Stimmung gibt, hat sich äh.
Ja äh bestätigt so. Das war,
ist ein Koalitionsvertrag, der sich im Bereich der Digitalpolitik dann doch sehr, sehr schön liest,
Und ähm in dem tatsächlich eine ganze Reihe Dinge äh angekündigt.
Werden, die wir hier in dieser Sendung.
Der CCC, in den äh Formulierungshilfen, wir als CCC in vielen Ausschüssen des Deutschen Bundestages ähm
immer wieder auch gefordert haben. Das führte dazu, dass einige Leute äh irgendwie
Mir begeisterte E-Mails geschrieben der äh CCC hätte jetzt die Politik gehackt und die Regierung übernommen oder solche Dinge. Ähm.
Also da muss man vielleicht mal so ein bisschen doch erklären, wie so ein Koalitionsvertrag zustande kommt. Also erstens,
Viele dieser Forderungen haben auch wir formuliert, ja und,
viele dieser Forderungen sind so alt, dass man, glaube ich, kaum noch die Urheberin jetzt finden kann, ja? Also beispielsweise die Sache mit äh Haftung für,
Sicherheitslücken in Software, die hab ich vor.
Weiß ich nicht, vor acht Jahren oder so schon im im äh Bundestagsausschuss, digitale Agenda gestellt und da war sie jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht so, dass mir das eingefallen ist, sondern diese.
Forderungen gab es ja sicherlich auch davor und es wird irgendwie ist äh schwierig, da jetzt am Ende zu sagen, die Person hat sich det erste Mal im Leben die Idee gehabt, ja ähm,
insofern schwer zurückzusuchen äh zu zu führen und dann muss man natürlich auch sagen, ähm in diesem ganzen Koalitionsvertrag,
steht nichts garantiert nichts, was nicht irgendeine Interessengruppe gefordert hat,
ja? Äh das da werden Dinge drinstehen, die haben, was weiß ich, die Grünen, die FDP, die SPD schon in ihrem Wahlprogramm angekündigt, ja, weil,
Jemand das auch schon mal gefordert hat. Ja, aber da finde ich's natürlich jetzt nicht sinnvoll oder auch nicht zielführend, jetzt diesen Parteien
irgendwie zu unterstellen, die hätten diese diese Position nicht auch selber gehabt, ne? Da also auf die grüne Partei blicken, äh auf die FDP blicken. Die haben ja auch in der Vergangenheit diese Positionen vertreten.
Die haben ja auch, gibt ja einen Grund, warum äh wir als CCC regelmäßig in Ausschüssen des deutschen Bundestags fahren, geladen von häufig linke oder Grüne
weil die wussten, dass das, was wir sagen würden, ihrer politischen Haltung äh entspricht. Ja, insofern den da jetzt ihre eigenen Gestaltungswillen äh oder ihre eigenen Entscheidungshoheit äh
sprechen, halte ich da jetzt für eine sehr ähm.
Sehr sportliche Interpretation dessen, was geschehen ist. Nichtsdestotrotz äh muss man ja sagen, ja, CC hat eine relativ ausführliche Formulierungshilfe geleistet und von unseren Forderungen sind dort sehr viele auch berücksichtigt worden.
So das ist doch äh eine eine sehr schöne Sache und äh das äh,
zeigt, dass man hier, ich würde jetzt mal sagen, das interpretiere ich also man kommt hier mit sinnvollen Forderungen.
Trifft man bei diesen Parteien zunächst einmal äh offenbar auf fruchtbaren Boden. Das ist doch schön.
Ja ist doch äh hat auch Substanz, ist doch äh schön. Aber ich denke auch, dass es äh das kann können sich jetzt nicht einzelne äh auch den CCC nicht da auf die Fahnen schreiben, somit weil das da jetzt steht, deswegen gibt's das nur, sondern.
Ja, das ist lächerlich. Es ist also steht so ein Satz drin wie für öffentliche IT-Projekte schreiben wir offene Standards fest, Entwicklungsaufträge werden in der Regel als Open Source beauftragt, die entsprechende Software wird grundsätzlich öffentlich gemacht.
Nennt sich Public Money Public Code.
Ist eine Forderung der äh Free-Software Foundation Europe glaube ich. Die hatten diese Kampagne damals gestartet. Ja und die waren auch wieder nicht die Ersten, ja. Äh wir führen ein Recht auf Verschlüsselung, ein wirksames Schwachstellen-Management,
mit dem Ziel Sicherheitslücken zu schließen und die Vorgaben Security bei Design äh Security bei DeFord ein. Ja, sehr schön,
und äh staatliche Stellen müssen ihnen bekannte Sicherheitslücken dem BSI melden. Hm sehr schön. Äh das heißt,
das identifizieren melden und schließen von Sicherheitslücken ist in einem verantwortlichen Verfahren zum Beispiel in der IT-Sicherheitsforschung äh legal durchzuführen, ja. Ähm,
Ach so, sorry, äh äh falsch verstanden den Satz. Also das Identifizieren, melden und schließen von Sicherheitslücken äh,
in einem verantwortlichen Verfahren zum Beispiel der IT-Sicherheitsforschung soll legal durchführbar sein. Das ist hier quasi der Punkt ähm ne äh äh,
du wirst verklagt, weil du weil die irgendjemand eine Schwachstelle gemeldet hast. Haben wir ja in diesem Jahr tatsächlich einige sehr obskure Fälle von gehabt. Ähm.
Verschlüsselung, sehr viel Stärkung, ja, Hersteller haften für Schäden, hatte ich gerade gesagt, soll steht da drin. Ähm äh die digitale Souveränität
Ja, das sind dann auch wieder, ne, dann kommen auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall die großen Worte, ne? Offene Standards, Open-Source, europäische
Ökosysteme bei fünf G oder KI und jetzt finde ich das sehr da sieht man's auch schon dieser ganze Digitalpolitikteil ist glaube ich irgendwie drei Seiten oder sowas ja.
Da ist halt viel drin, aber das sind ja jetzt keine Gesetze, sondern das sind ja quasi die Ziele, auf die sie sich geeinigt haben. Und wie dieser Koalitionsvertrag oder wie jetzt quasi die am Ende in Gesetzqualität stehen.
Das ist das, was man dann eben äh noch sehen wird. Insofern, wie gesagt, Verhalten äußerst positiv, aber ähm,
muss man mal gucken, jeder äh Koalitionsvertrag liest sich ja wirklich wie eben der äh der Beginn,
der neuen Zeit, ja? Äh wie äh das ist übrigens auch bei den Koalitionsverträgen, äh die irgendwelche CDU und SPD schreiben.
Immer mit ganz viel Zukunft und so.
Ganz viel Zukunft und nachhaltig und Reichtum für alle und genau und also so.
Landschaften.
Ganze Prozess ja, das war jetzt auch also es war,
ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob's das erste Mal war, dass der CCC eine Formulierungshilfe geliefert hat. Vor allem war's aber auf jeden Fall eine ausführlich. Die nach meiner Kenntnis die ausführlichste und der ist auch so ziemlich viel Arbeit reingeflossen und wir sind auch natürlich äußerst happy,
diese Arbeit nicht umsonst war.
Aber das machen eben im Prinzip alle, ne? Und ich war auch als Vertreter des CCC dann bei solchen Treffen mit äh den Parteien
die in den Koalitionsvertragsverhandlungen waren, da gibt's dann Arbeitsgruppe so und so, ne und die laden dann die äh die relevanten Stakeholder, die sie,
identifiziert haben oder die sich an sie gewendet haben ein zum Gespräch und das sind dann große Runden. Ja und da sind dann halt viele, viele Leute, die was weiß ich,
Partikularinteressen, Wirtschaftsinteressen, äh zivilgesellschaftliche Interessen da einbringen und da sitzen natürlich, was weiß ich, bei der
Bei den Grünen eine etwas andere Mischung als vielleicht bei der FDP oder bei der SPD, aber in diesem Bereich, jetzt sage ich mal, progressive Digitalpolitik, da
äh rennt man glaube ich zumindest bei FDP und Grünen offene Türen ein und auch in großen Teilen der SPD, muss man ja mal sagen. So. Das sieht schon gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Digitale Bürgerrechte und die IT-Sicherheit soll gestärkt gestärkt werden ähm,
digitale Demokratie und Gesellschaft soll gestärkt werden, also algorithmische Systeme sollen überprüfbar sein Gesetz gegen digitale Gewalt äh soll Betroffene unterstützen.
Da das sind eben immer alles so Sachen, na ja müssen wir mal gucken, was da noch so wie das dann wirklich am Ende als Gesetz steht, ne.
Da noch mal ein bisschen durchgehen.
Ja, klingt alles sehr schön, ne?
Wie du schon gesagt hast, wie so Koalitionsverträge halt äh immer schön klingen, ja, die äh das wird dann noch lustig werden, das in den nächsten Jahren dann äh abzuklopfen, was wirklich dabei rausgekommen ist, ne.
Einerseits was den Druck innerhalb der Parteien betrifft, die dann vielleicht dann doch noch auf andere Ideen kommen und sich von irgendeiner gefühlten öffentlichen Meinung noch leiten lassen oder eben was sich eben auch auf europäischer Ebene noch alles so an Zwängen ergibt.
Na ja.
Recht auf Interoporabilität und Portailität, ne? Das ist ja auch so eine Sache, wo du jetzt sagst, also Datenportabilität ist eine Sache. Aber wenn du jetzt sagst, wenn du jetzt sagst, Interoperabilität sagst, okay, Freemar soll jetzt mit WhatsApp operabel werden.
Wird halt nicht ganz so einfach, ne? Ähm.
IT-Sicherheitsarchitektur soll um umgebaut werden, dass BSI soll unabhängiger sein und staatliche Meldepflicht für Sicherheitslücken.
Das wird halt spannend. Abschaffung des HK Paragraphen, Ablehnung von Heckbacks, so äh,
Das wäre so dieser dieser Bereich, den wir im im CCC immer als, ne, defensive oder rein defensive, kompromisslos defensive Ausrichtung der IT-Sicherheitspolitik bezeichnet, ne,
Also Staat darf nicht gegen die Interessen der Bürger äh Sicherheitslücken geheimhalten.
Sicherheitsforscher dürfen nicht kriminalisiert werden. Staat darf nicht äh offensiv in diesem Bereich agieren, sondern soll eben alle seine Interessen auf die Sicherheit,
fokussieren und das ist hier so,
angekündigt. Dazu legen wir ein großes Maßnahmenpaket vor. Ja? Wir stärken die digitale Demokratie und Gesellschaft, ja, algorithmische Systeme überprüfbar.
Da wird dann viel Tech gefördert, das ist da können wir dann auch hoffen, dass hier unsere beiden Gäste aus der letzten Sendung äh potentiell.
Äh darauf hoffen können, dass ihr souverän Tech Fund auch äh tatsächlich äh Realisierung findet, ne.
Absage an die Identifizierungspflicht, anonyme und pseudonyme Nutzung soll beibehalten werden. Ja,
Also das sieht schon alles ganz ganz okay aus, aber auch richterlich angeordnete Accountsperren und da gibt es eine Idee
die sich auch dort drin findet, die wir ich glaube hier noch gar nicht besprochen haben. Und zwar ist das die,
sogenannte Login Falle. Kennst.
Ähm habe ich schon mal was von gehört, dass man sozusagen bei Diensten.
Login Falle geht so. Die sagen im Prinzip, also sagen,
Okay, wir müssen also Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
sagt ja OK wir wollen die IP-Adresse, wir wollen IP-Adressen loggen und so weiter äh von allen immer um im Zweifelsfall darauf zugreifen zu können. Ja? Also du möchtest wissen.
Gibt's von mir aus irgendeinen anonymen Internetaccount, von dem wird jetzt eine äh Straftat begangen. Ja?
Beleidigung oder über das Schlimmer. So und jetzt möchtest du wissen, wer ist dat?
Ja und der beste Weg, weil die Leute, du kannst ja anonyme E-Mail-Adressen holen, du kannst die meisten Dienste anonym nutzen, du musst sie auch anonym nutzen dürfen. Ja? Das heißt, der beste Weg, eine Person zu identifizieren, ist dann,
natürlich die IP-Adresse. Die sagt dir nämlich wenigstens die Anschlussinhaberin. Ja und das wäre jetzt etwas mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder eben,
Logging-Pflicht auf Seiten der Provider, dass man eben sagt so, wir wollen immer die IP-Adresse wissen von jemandem, der irgendwann eingeloggt war, ne? Große Datenberge und so weiter. Zu dieser Idee alternativ positioniert sich,
der dieses Konzept der Log-In-Falle.
Und die soll folgendermaßen also die die soll sich positionieren als Alternative,
zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und die soll funktionieren ungefähr so, dass du jetzt quasi ähm.
Sagst ähm du meldest jetzt irgendwie okay von diesem Account ging eine äh Beleidigung aus ja und dann wird gesagt okay,
wir möchten keine Klarnahmen, keine Identifizierungspflicht, all das nicht haben, sondern dieser Account, alle existierenden Logins werden ausgelockt,
Ja, du bist einfach nicht mehr bei Facebook angemeldet oder bei Twitter oder was auch immer du da verwendet hast. Und du bist natürlich jetzt äh dran. Du musst dich neu anmelden.
Und quasi bei dem nächsten Login wird die IP-Adresse dann gespeichert.
Und an die Ermittlungsbehörde übermittelt. Und der nächste Login ist deshalb, weil quasi gesagt wird, das nächste Mal, wenn sich die Authentifizierte Person mit uns verbindet oder ähm,
bei uns noch einmal authentifiziert,
dann kann geben wir die IP sofort raus an die Behörden und dann können die Behörden sofort von dem äh Tele- und Kommunikations äh Anbieter eine Stammdatenauskunft machen und den äh Anschluss ähm.
Inhaber äh zumindest identifizieren.
Das äh Konzept hat ähD64 vorgestellt, der äh SPD nahe Thinktank relativ viele SPD-Mitglieder drin sind. Ähm wann haben.
Glaube ich nicht mehr selber nicht mehr so gerne hören und auch äh.
Nichts ändern, da müssen sie halt irgendwie die Hälfte vom Vorstand rauswerfen.
Ich sag's nur.
Tut mir leid ja ähm na ja ist ja auch in also,
ich finde das jetzt auch gar nicht schlimm, ja, äh zu sagen, das ist SPD. Na, ist doch schön, wenn man es wenn man auch in der SPD nahe etwas,
ein ein progressiven das Zentrum für digitalen Fortschritte.
Aber Sie legen Wert drauf, dass Sie jetzt auch äh viele Mitglieder haben, die sich mit dem mit dem Etikett SPDnah jetzt nicht unbedingt schmücken lassen möchten.
Ja, das machen die aber glaube ich eher deshalb nicht, weil sie sich da gerade nicht mitschmücken können. So oder konnten in den letzten Jahren. Klar, da ist ja auch also Co-Vorsitzende ist Marina Weißband, äh die ja äh früher bei den Piraten boah,
ist auch ist auch völlig egal. Äh ich finde das.
Ja sind auch ähm,
Unternehmen drin, ja irgendwie das die haben jemand im Vorstand, der ist bei Vodafone in Big Data und Consumer Analytics.
Aha, Kommunisten also.
Ja also das ist nicht so ähm,
das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie eine eine Gras-Fruits-Bewegung von irgendwelchen äh Idealistinnen und Idealisten, sondern Leute, die äh in diesem Bereich äh auch professionell unterwegs sind und wie gesagt, das,
du du tust jetzt so als klinge das schlimm. Äh das finde ich jetzt überhaupt nicht verkehrt, weil ich habe einfach nur gesagt, es sie sind SPD nah und da hast du widersprochen.
Ich habe ich habe ich ich gebe den Widerspruch, den ich gehört habe, als ich das denen gegenüber behauptet habe, wieder also.
Ich höre auch nicht gerne, dass ich fünf Kilo über.
Ich ich habe dem nicht widersprochen. Das kann durchaus sein, dass sie noch SPD nah sind. Ich weiß nur, dass sie selber diesen diese diese Beschreibung nicht mehr gerne hören. Das ist was ganz anderes.
Lass uns lass uns mal hier bei der Position bleiben. Also diese ich finde ich wichtig weil diese Position ist ist sinnvoll ja und die haben ja auch andere Positionen, fünf Gründe für Open Source Software und so das ist nicht alles ähm.
Nee, nicht alles äh falsch, was die machen. So und diese Idee der Login-Falle hat sich jetzt auch in diesem Koalitions,
Vertrag gefunden, ne? Das nehme ich jetzt erstmal, weil wir das Konzept hier noch nicht besprochen hatten und weil ähm.
Weil es eben auch zeigt, ne, dass hier eine andere Gruppierung, die auch eine Forderung hatte, die mir ebenfalls in diesen Koalitionsvertrag geschafft hat. Ähm übrigens auch die,
ein FDP-Abgeordneter hat dann erstmal eine ausführliche,
ausführiges Interview bei bei der bei Faz in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung gegeben. Es wird ein Quantensprung sein,
nämlich die neue Blockchain-Politik der Bundesregierung. Es ist nicht alles gut, ja? Irgend so ein
FDP-Typ, der nicht weiß, wie klein ein Quantensprung ist. Ähm er hat dann da eben erzählt, dass jetzt hier die die neue Blockchain äh,
Frühling kommen wird.
Ein Januswort ist das, der Quantensprung.
Äh
Anonymisierung fördern, Standards für Anonymisierung schaffen, Strafbarkeit für Deanonymisierung, Rechtsanspruch auf open-Data
ähm bessere Durchsetzung von Datenschutz kohärenterer Datenschutz, Institutionalisierung der Datenschutzkonferenz äh und damit auch rechtlichere rechtliche Verbindlichkeit dieser Datenschutzkonferenzbeschlüsse.
Ähm da was haben wir denn noch? Äh den europäischen Forschungsforschungsstandort äh stärken,
Rechtsgrundlage und Transparent für digitale Informationen in der,
Innovationen in der Verwaltung. Okay, das wird natürlich spannend. Also digitale Innovation in der Verwaltung ist ein ist ein großer das sind große Ziele, ne.
Äh digitale Bürgerrechte, Waren, Diskriminierungsfreiheit in der Artificial Intelligence sicherstellen.
Gegen biometrische Erkennungen der Öffentlichkeit, ja, sieht alles echt gar nicht so. Es sieht wirklich alles ganz gut aus, ja. Das muss man,
schon mal,
so sagen, aber ich finde möchte auch gleichzeitig immer wieder sagen, dass ich da jetzt nicht äh das noch nicht der Moment ist zu jubeln.
So, sondern zu sagen.
Also vom Papier her kann man sich jetzt erst mal noch nicht beschweren. Das werden wir dann erst später machen, wenn das was auf dem Papier steht nichts mehr wert ist.
Es ist halt also,
also viele Dinge in in der in der Politik und in der IT in der Netzpolitik sind äh,
halt wirklich am Ende juristische Haarspalterei, die irgendwie zwischen Erfolg und Misserfolg entscheidet, ne? Beispiel.
Hier ähm digitale Gewalt, Beleidigung, Stalking und so weiter, ne. Da ist sind sich,
alle ja einig, dass man da ein dass wir da ein Problem haben in dieser Gesellschaft,
und dass wir da auch nicht ausreichend äh Strafverfolgungsaussichten haben, wenn so etwas passiert. Ja, wir haben ja die vielen ne denke an das Künast-Urteil äh denke, weißt du, wenn dich jetzt irgendjemand im Internet beleidigt, dass,
diese Person dafür bestraft wird ist ja quasi ausgeschlossen im Prinzip ne. Also wir haben hier ein Problem, das ist bekannt.
Und da sind Sie auch alle drüber einig. Jetzt ist das Problem, wie willst du dem begegnen? Wie willst du es sinnvoll tun, ja, dass dieses Verhalten eingedämmt wird und du möglichst nicht viel weitere Kinder mit dem Bad ausgießt? Das ist ja dann immer,
das ist dann eben die Quadratur des Kreises, die dann eben eine sinnvolle Digitalpolitik ist. Und da haben wir jetzt in den in den vorangegangenen Legislaturperioden eben auch viel gesehen.
Wo was weiß ich. Wir machen jetzt eine IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und so weiter, wo wo du auch sagen willst, das klingt erst mal sinnvoll.
Ja und aber wie's dann aussieht, dass das dann so auszuformulieren, dass es wirklich sinnvoll ist und sinnvoll wirkt,
ist ja nicht nicht ganz so einfach ne.
Aber ich möchte trotzdem äh noch eine ähm Kolumne von Chris Stöcker erwähnen. Ne, der war ja früher der Leiter der Netzwelt, weil Spiegel ist jetzt äh irgendwie in Hamburg an einer.
Geworden, hm?
Uni ja seit einiger Zeit schon, ne? Ähm der Vorgänger von äh Judith Heuch hat die ja auch bei uns mal in der Sendung war.
Und äh endlich konservative Digitalpolitik
was ich äh total schön finde, weil er nämlich sagt, ja der CCC, ne, grade 40 Jahre alt geworden und wir haben quasi
traditionelle Werte, ja, die Bewahrung, Grundprinzipien, ähm ne, die Hacker-Ethik und ähm,
Diese acht Gebote bescheren einen idealistischen, optimistischen Geist, den Geist einer freien, fairen, digitalen Welt, in der man mit Computern, Kunst und Schönheit schaffen kann und Computer dein Leben
zum Besseren verändern. Äh die,
auch eine schöne Bild-Textschere, weil äh das das Artikelbild ist so ein Laptop wahrscheinlich irgendwo aufm Kongress oder so fotografiert, wo der Aufkleber drauf ist, dass Internet,
leben. Leichter leichte Bildtextile. Und sagte eben so, jetzt kommt eine konservative, wertorientierte Netzpolitik äh in Deutschland.
Und äh das ist durchaus richtig, ne, also dass man sieht in diesem Ampelkoalitionsvertrag weht eben auch dieser äh Wind.
Und er setzt dann hier eben einige Sätze aus dem Koalitionsvertrag mit der Hacker Ethik gegenüber und zeigt das hier dann eben die traditionellen Werte,
haben.
Vertreten sind. Zitiert äh Markus Becke da, let's fility org. Äh wir leben in spannenden Zeiten, aber jetzt gibt es etwas mehr Hoffnung, dass sich unsere ja langjährige Arbeit endlich auszahlt und eine lebenswerte, digitale Gesellschaft möglicher
erscheint. Ähm der Koalitionsvertrag enthält zahlreiche Sätze, die man gerne unterschreiben will. So schön.
Und dann hatte der Erdgeist noch ein Interview gegeben in der äh Zeit. Erdgeister wie gesagt einer der Hauptautoren von den,
ähm von den ähm von den Formulierungshilfen, wo er eben auch mal so sagt, dass äh erfreulich viele Punkte,
die eben zu Denkanstößen und zu klaren Bekenntnissen geführt haben.
Und das Interview hat den Titel die Bundesregierung muss das digitale Analphabetentum abschaffen und ich glaube in in dem in dem äh Satz sagt in dem in dem Interview sagt er noch was sehr viel schöneres, nämlich dass man damit auch kokettieren kann.
Ja? Also dass man dass es ja irgendwie so ich habe ja vorm Computer gar keine Ahnung. Das kannst du halt eigentlich heute auch nicht mehr. Äh das das darf nicht mehr äh akzeptabel sein, ja.
Genau hier ähm,
Es wandelt an einer digitalen Grundbildung in Deutschland, wo sich eine Bundeskanzlerin hinstellt und damit kokettiert, dass Digitalisierung ja eh Neuland sei und nicht so schlimm, wenn man sich nicht auskenne,
man nicht vorbereitet auf die Zukunft.
Wir sehen das auch immer wieder in Gesprächen mit Lehrerinnen, Richterinnen, Beamten, Mitarbeitern in Behörden, die Grundsätze des Digitalen werden oft nicht verstanden.
Und äh da muss ich etwas dran ändern. Ja, finde ich auch sehr richtig. Es muss inakzeptabel werden mit Technik und Kenntnis zu kokettieren.
Unterschreiben. Steht allerdings nicht.
Ah, das hätte ganz gut gepasst. Ja, das muss aber auch wirklich, das ist das ist schön formuliert. Also das das muss wirklich ein Ende haben. Immer so dieses ja, ich mache ja alles noch,
analog, also,
diese ganze Analogdiskussion. Die Welt ist nicht analog, vergesst es, ja. Die ganze Welt ist digital. Das haben wir spätestens jetzt mit diesen Impfstoffen gelernt. Also wenn man sich das mal anschaut irgendwie,
der ganze Planet ist digital. Hier das ganze Leben, die ganze Evolution ist eine reine Digitalisierung von von unten da oben, akzeptiert's einfach.
Auch gern noch mal herleiten.
Ja, aber das heißt, wir könnten äh potenziell eine äh Situation haben, in der äh wir jetzt erst mal.
Ähm erstens sehr viel erfreulichere äh Gesetzespakete in der Digitalpolitik sehen.
Ich sehe schon wie unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer sich diesen Tag irgendwie rot markieren.
An Unsub scripe, an Subscribe.
Och, jetzt wird's langweilig.
Die ersten zehn Jahre waren noch lustig, aber dann wurd's irgendwie langweilig. Ähm und äh ja aber es gibt auch noch genug hier zu tun, dass man dass man das das wird jetzt noch nicht irgendwie der.
Pass bloß auf, wenn du hier nichts mehr zu randen hast und so, dann wehen alle aus Protest AfD.
Ich mache mir überhaupt gar keine Sorgen. Wir werden schon genug haben, wo man das bei uns noch aufregen können. Also ne
da da lasse ich mich erstmal von überhaupt nichts beeinflussen. Ich habe auch diesen ganzen Konditionszirkus ehrlich gesagt, der ist halt noch gar nicht so richtig zur Kenntnis genommen. Mich interessieren einfach nur Fakten.
Ja, das ist,
Aber äh ne du musst dich ja dazu verhalten, wenn du wenn du jahrelang politische Forderungen aufstellst, auf einmal stehen im Koalitionsvertrag, dann sagst du natürlich, schön, gut, finden wir richtig. Ja, jetzt auch machen,
nicht nicht nur sagen, machen
Und dummerweise muss man natürlich auch sagen, dass das potenziell äh auch äh einiges an Arbeit für uns bedeutet und jetzt ist wir,
also es äh wir drohen in der ungewohnten äh Situation zu landen als Sachverständige in Ausstößen des deutschen Bundestags äh für die Regierung da zu sitzen, nicht für die Opposition und ähm.
Also für die Positionen der Regierung oder im im im Interesse der Regierung dort zu sitzen. Müssen wir mal gucken, wie wie da so die Arbeit läuft. Insgesamt muss ich nochmal sagen,
habe, also kenne ich in der FDP und bei den Grünen.
Auf jeden Fall eine Reihe an Digitalpolitikern, die den den Themenbereich verstanden und durchdrungen haben, ja? Wenn du so ein äh Manuel Höverlin und so ein Konstantin Kuhle nimmst, die die wissen schon,
da läuft, ja und die haben da auch insgesamt eine relativ ähm äh korrekte Einstellung. So und das äh hast du bei den Grünen,
ohnehin ne das Konstantin von Notz ist ja hier allen bekannt und dann so Leute wie Malte Spitze oder so sind ja alle bekannt ja das äh schon in Ordnung und bei der SPD äh gab's ja immerhin auch äh Saskia Esken.
Die gibt's alle, ne? Mal gucken, ob ob dann am Ende auch jemand auf sie hört. Also das ähm ist ja auch bei so äh SPD-Vorsitzenden jetzt nicht unbedingt immer die Regel.
Ja, nicht so keine Garantie. Okay, dann haben wir äh eine Nachricht, die also haben wir die.
Nein haben wir nämlich äh noch nicht und äh auch nicht die Rahmenbedingungen, unter denen das stattgefunden äh hat, haben wir auch noch nicht besprochen.
Ja, es geht gegen äh die NSO-Group, ne? Also hier oft schon äh verflucht und drüber berichtet worden.
Ähm dieses Unternehmen aus Israel, was Pegasus und anderes Beiware herstellt und schön an alle Länder der Welt auch verkauft, meistbietend äh
dann halt dazu nutzen, um Journalisten oder andere Regimekritiker,
auszuhorchen, quasi über ihre Smartphones abzuhören und zu überwachen.
Und sieht so aus, als ob das mittlerweile auch den USA äh ordentlich über die Leber gelaufen ist,
denn äh die USA haben Sanktionen gegen die NSU Group und auch noch ein, zwei andere Unternehmen ähm verhängt. Damit ging's ja irgendwie äh los, Anfang dieses Monats.
Und äh ja haben die jetzt auf so eine Liste gesetzt, ähm die für die dann Handelsbeschränkungen gelten. Eine sogenannte,
List.
Und da äh rieb ich mir schon ein wenig die Augen und äh gab da noch mehr zu. Mehr zu reiben.
Als dann äh kurze Zeit später äh Apple aufn Plan trat und äh sogar eine Klage gegen die NSU Group angestoßen hat, sondern mit der Argumentation
hier äh was ihr macht mit unseren Telefonen. Das ist einfach mal nicht zulässig und wir wollen euch das jetzt untersagen,
dass ihr hier auf diese Art und Weise die Integrität unserer Betriebssysteme äh untergräbt.
Und ja das äh haben sie jetzt in den USA gestartet,
nicht das richtig sehe, wollen sie halt auch alles dafür tun, um Leute davon in Kenntnis zu setzen, wenn Apple,
aus ihrer Perspektive, wie auch immer sie diese gewinnen, äh das Gefühl haben, dass einzelne Telefone von Pegasus-Software attackiert worden sind.
Ja und äh offensichtlich äh hat das ziemlich Wellen geschlagen, weil mittlerweile sogar auch Israel,
selber äh Exportbeschränkungen jetzt aufgerufen.
Hat und äh jetzt diesen äh Export der sogenannten Hochtechnologie äh nur noch in 37 statt 12 Länder erlaubt. Also die haben sozusagen
hier eine eine Reduktion der Export ähm.
Erlaubnis ja oder eine Ausweitung der Exportbeschränkungen, je nachdem wie man das sehen will, äh durchgesetzt.
Und ähm das hat wohl dazu geführt, dass jetzt Länder wie Marokko,
Mexiko, Saudi-Arabien, Vereinigte Arabische Emirate aus dieser Exportliste äh gestrichen wurden,
ohne dass sie jetzt groß erklärt hätten, warum eigentlich.
Mit diesen Exportrestriktionen musste natürlich äh.
Dran denken, dass das etwas ist, die zu umgehen, ist halt ein einfacher Sport, insbesondere im Softwarebereich und genau darum geht es ja in dem ähm Strafverfahren gegen Finnfischer, die,
unter anderem deutsche Unternehmenskonglomerat, das ja ähm.
Diesen Staats ebenfalls einen Staatstrianer im Angebot hat, ebenfalls äh gekauft von deutschen Behörden und von äh unterschiedlichen Ländern, in dem Fall, den wir da analysiert haben, geht's da um den Einsatz in der Türkei gegen die Opposition und da eben auch
letztendlich äh um einen nicht genehmigten Export und.
Grundsätzlich umgehst du Exportrestriktionen halt durch so einen ja im Prinzip so wie du Tor,
mit einem Tor Browser irgendwie durch verschiedene Juristriktionen landerst. Ne, also ein bisschen fest und das äh,
kann halt auch sein dass die das hier dann tun werden. Ne also das
so eine Exportrestriktion ist nicht aller Tage Abend und wenn du solche Produkte hast, dann weißt du auch, an wen du dich wenden musst, zumal ne das ist eben was anderes zu sagen, ihr dürft eure scheiß Panzer nicht mehr in bestimmte Länder liefern, sondern ihr müsst hier nach Saudi-Arabien liefern, damit sie von da weiterverkauft werden können.
Ne ähm oder eben eine Software der die zu handeln eben ja wirklich an Grenzen sehr schwer zu kontrollieren ist.
Also das äh wollte ich damit auch nicht implizieren, dass damit jetzt sozusagen alle Probleme gelöst sind, aber es ist natürlich schon bemerkenswert, wenn der Staat Israel selber gegen ein Unternehmen äh im eigenen Lande ja und,
Israelis ja bekannt für ihre Anführungsstrichen, Hochtechnologie und äh hat ja ein Interesse da dran, quasi
an allen Fronten Number one zu sein oder zumindest äh in der in der Spitze mit zu äh laufen. Ähm dass sie trotzdem solche Einschränkungen machen, weil sie letzten Endes entweder,
Also könnte mir zweierlei Motivation vorstellen. Das eine könnte sein, das könnte eine Reaktion auf den internationalen Druck sein, so nach dem Motto, was macht ihr da,
Ja äh wenn ihr da jetzt nicht mal einschreitet, dann werden wir äh ORLs ne, dass sie das aus der Motivation heraus gemacht haben. Das könnte ein Grund oder,
Ein Teil eines Grundes sein, ein anderer Teil des Grundes könnte sein, dass sie auch selbst eine andere,
Risikobewertungen vornehmen, weil's ja am Ende auch in bestimmten Staaten wie zum Beispiel im arabischen Raum auch ihr eigenes Interesse sozusagen untergräbt.
Ne? Also ist ja immer das Problem mit den Sicherheitslücken, ne? Du trittst ja damit selber was ein.
Also was es halt gibt ist ähm kann ich jetzt mal vorsichtig sagen, dass wir auch bekannt ist, das sagen wir mal, die Deutschen,
der äh Innenpolitik, die ja äh Kundinnen bei äh
NSO sind, ne? Das werde ich vergessen. Ist ja auch erst vor Kurzem rausgekommen. Haben sie auch wieder nirgendwo erzählt, aber wurde dann eben durch investigativ hier das äh NDR in Investigativteam da äh Rechercheverbund waren das doch glaube ich jetzt rausgefunden hatten. Nachdem es diesen NSO-Skandal gab, dass sie sagten, ja hier die Deutschen haben das auch gekauft. Ähm,
Die lesen natürlich auch ungern so was in der Zeitung,
ja und sagen halt, wir würden gerne lieber mit anderen Kundinnen und Kunden auf der Liste stehen. Ja und da das kann dann schon auch ein internationaler äh ökonomischer Druck sein.
Aber äh was hälst du denn von dieser Sache, dass Apple äh LSO verklagt hat?
Na ja, ich meine, was halten was halte ich davon? Also ich nehme das erstmal so zur Kenntnis, ne. Sie wollen ja ähm,
nicht näher bezifferte Wiedergutmachung äh sozusagen auch einfordern für das Ausspähen ihrer äh Nutzer,
Und ähm ja, ich find's vor allem dahingehend besonders. Also erstmal wusste ich gar nicht, dass sie das das das ist sozusagen dafür eine eine juristische Handhabe zu geben scheint im US Recht.
Also ich glaube, dass Sie schon nicht so ein,
einfachen Case haben vor dem Gericht und ich glaube nicht, dass es ein unmittelbares Gesetz gibt, was sagt, äh wenn deine Geräte äh gehackt werden, äh
die du in Umlauf gebracht hast. Äh kannst du jetzt den denjenigen, der es tut, verklagen. Aber Sie sagen im Prinzip,
Sie unterstellen hier in dieser in diesem ähm Complain sagen sie okay also die haben,
ähm entwickelt, verkauft und äh,
operated ähm Offensive und destruktive Schadsoftware. Ähm.
Und die wurden genutzt, um äh abzuziehen und anzugreifen. Apple Kunden, Apple Produkte und Apple.
Ja und sagen und das machen sie mit kommerziellem,
Interesse. Also sie bringen ihre Kunden ihre ihre eigenen Services und sich selber da mit rein, um quasi ähm äh,
quasi ähm ihren Schaden geltend zu machen, damit sie überhaupt einen Case haben gegen dieses Unternehmen.
Genau, weil das ja auch mal mit Terms of Condition so die ähm also die wie heißt das, Toms, also die Bedingungen, die äh waren ja sozusagen zu denen man sich ja bereit erklärt, die einzuhalten, wenn man äh entsprechende Accounts aufmacht et cetera.
Genau. Äh,
Jetzt kommt hier der entscheidende Satz, dass Sie sagen, container on apple servers, but did abuse apple services and service to pertate attacks,
Users
ein Data Store on Users Devices und das ist glaube ich das ist der entscheidende Hebel, dass sie sagen, sie haben unsere Server benutzt oder unsere Services, unser iCloud, unser Hasse nicht gesehen und da wollen sie denn irgendwie drankommen.
Das, was ich bisher so gelesen und gehört habe.
Geht nicht unbedingt davon aus, dass Apple damit jetzt äh einen Homerun vor Gericht hat, ja? Aber,
Es gibt einen äh relativ eigentlich den Aspekt, den ich finde, den viele ähm nicht beachten. Ich glaube,
Allein die Rechtsabteilung von Apple ein größeres Jahresgehalt hat als dieses Unternehmen überhaupt wert ist. Ja ohne Dachri.
Als NSO wird.
Sehen, bin ich mir relativ ja, also wenn du ganz NSO nimmst, ist das wahrscheinlich nicht das Jahresgehalt, was diese Anwältinnen und Anwälte gesamt,
haben,
Meine meine vorsichtige Schätzung, um jetzt mal so zu sehen, wer da jetzt wie reich und wie stark und so weiter ist. Und natürlich wird NSO schon auch einiges wert sein, ne. Die kaufen ja auch äh teure Explodes ein und so weiter sind,
weltweit äh von von zweifelhaftem Ruf. Das ist meistens viel wert.
Aber Apple eben auch und ich glaube Apple ist halt immer noch eines der äh wertvollsten Unternehmen auf diesem Planeten und die können denen einfach sehr sehr viel Ärger machen.
Also zumindest wird's nicht am Geld scheitern.
Es wird Apple bei Apple nicht am Geld scheitern und und die NSO so da wirst du halt gehst du halt jetzt auch nicht,
weißt du, im Dorf zum nächsten Anwalt und sagst, hör mal, können wir da was machen? Ja, sondern da hast du natürlich jetzt auch erstmal signifikant ähm,
Investitionen,
Und der Punkt ist, wenn Apple diesen Fall verliert, ja und dann ein paar Millionen äh äh investiert hat, ist denen das quasi egal,
Weil sie genug Geld haben und schon allein dadurch, dass sie klagen, natürlich so ein bisschen einfach auch positive PR haben. Und drittens wahrscheinlich gleichzeitig lobbyieren, dass die Gesetze bald so sind, dass sie,
Hebel haben und das ist halt schon einfach glaube ich durchaus ein nennenswertes Ungleichgewicht, dass da jetzt halt auf die auf NSO einprügelt.
Ähm so, oh Shit, wir haben diese Rechtsabteilung von Apple äh irgendwie gegen uns und die
klagen in auf ihrem eigenen Home-Terf und wir brauchen wahrscheinlich jetzt Anwälte, die uns in den,
USA hier vor dem Northern District Court of California überhaupt verteidigen können. Da können wir jetzt auch nicht unsere Anwälte hier mitnehmen aus äh aus Israel, weil die da nicht zugelassen sind. Also das wird schon äh glaube ich äh
ist schon einfach ein empfindlicher Schaden den sie den überhaupt schon allein äh zufügen.
Ja, aber es könnte natürlich auch eine interessante juristische Präzedenz werden, ne, weil ihre Argumentation ist ja, dass das Unternehmen,
Ähm also NSO-Group Apple als Hersteller der Geräte geschadet hat und nicht nur,
und ausschließlich den betroffenen Personen. Sondern das ist sozusagen etwas ist, was Apple schadet, wenn die gegen die Geräte vorgehen und.
Wie gesagt, es gibt jetzt hier in den Artikeln, die ich gelesen habe und du hast ja wahrscheinlich auch nix gesehen und wir sind eh keine Juristen. Ist noch ein bisschen unklar.
Auf was sie das jetzt basieren. Ne, also ob's wirklich da eine eine eine Rechtsbasis in den USA bereits,
die wir so nicht kennen und bewerten können, auf der man so was machen kann. Aber wie du auch schon richtig sagtest,
sehr gut sein, dass es zumindest in diesem Prozess eben auch eine entsprechende Entwicklung geben könnte, dass dort nachgeschärft wird, weil ich glaube, dass natürlich die USA auch ein großes Interesse daran hat, beziehungsweise ist auch eine interessante juristische Perspe
ist zu sagen Unternehmen können sich auch gegen Angreifer,
aufm legalen Wege dagegen durchsetzen. Meine was bedeutet das als nächstes? Es könnte sein, dass irgendwie auch die Telekom gegen jeden klagen kann, der irgendwie ähm
ne, auf Telekom äh Dienste gesetzt hat, et cetera,
oder was weiß ich, Cisco, andere äh Netzwerkgerätehersteller hätte im Prinzip äh den gleichen Hebel.
Und das macht natürlich die Situation für so ein Unternehmen, ja, die einfach sich hinstellen und sagen, so, wir machen euch alles auf,
Ja? Kein Problem, kommt her, gebt uns euer unser Geld. Macht's natürlich jetzt ähm im Bereich der Rechtssicherheit nicht unbedingt einfacher für die.
Ja, das ist schon also ist ganz interessant. Was ich also kann man auf jeden Fall mit Interesse verfolgen. Wie gesagt
glaube erstmal, dass sie jetzt nicht unbedingt die beste Startposition haben. Aber umso schöner, wenn sie die, wenn sie die ausbauen. Weil wenn also auf jeden Fall haben sie, glaube ich, ganz gute äh ganz gute Rechtsabteilungen bei Apple, was ich,
auch natürlich sehr schön finde ist, dass ähm die Forschung des Citizon Lab und äh von Amnesty International hier ähm,
auch eben Erwähnung findet, ne, weil darf man ja nicht äh nicht ähm,
selten genug sagen, sowohl äh nicht kann man ja nicht oft genug betonen. Ähm,
sowohl dieses Strafverfahren gegen Finnfischer wegen Exportkontrollen, wurde ja angeleiert von der zivilen IT-Security-Forschung.
Ja? Also ähm jetzt muss ich gerade mal gucken, wer alles da noch mit untersucht hatte, ne, aber äh die haben wir alle in unseren Quellen verlinkt, äh Excess Now war da glaube ich drin. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob
Amnesty da war äh also aber auch eigentlich diese gesamte Staatstrojanerforschungsgemeinschaft, die ja relativ klein ist, ähm hat da äh eben auch mitgewirkt und deren Analysen sind ja auch vor Gericht.
Oder in diesem Strafverfahren dann eben eingebracht wurden äh in der in dem Strafantrag inklusive der die Thorsten und ich geschrieben haben und dann hier dieser eben zu sehen so jetzt
ne? Die unsere Freunde vom Citizen Lab und unsere Freunde von Amnesty International werden jetzt hier in ähm Strafanträgen,
als Zeugen benannt oder ne äh für das Vorgehen von Apple gegen diese fucking NSO groove. Das ist schon äh ganz geil, ne und jetzt darf man muss man wieder daran erinnern so, ne? Das ähm
Citizon Lab, ist eine kleine äh Einrichtung an der University of Toronto. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Leute da sind, aber nicht viele
ne, geleitet von äh Ronald Divert, habe ich auch mal kennengelernt und ähm netter Typ, der sich da eben quasi in dieser,
IT-Sicherheitsforschung in diesem Bereich seit sehr langer Zeit eben auch spezialisiert mit einem Team, das ja auch viele Jahre da schon arbeitet oder äh damit assoziiert ist oder loser assoziiert ist noch.
Dann äh bei Amnesty. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute bei Amnesty in dem äh in dem Privacy,
Ding sind, ja. Ähm das sind auch nur ein paar Personen. Ja und das ist natürlich dann schon ähm geil, wenn du mit so ein paar.
Weltklasse-Leuten,
das du halt hinkriegst ja? Dass sie überhaupt dieses Zero-Day gefunden haben dass sie das gemeldet haben an Apple, dass Apple daraus jetzt halt auch irgendwie nicht sagt jo vielen Dank hier sind eure Credits sondern sagt alles klar die Penner machen wir platt so das ist schon ganz geil.
Freue ich mich auf jeden Fall sehr, dass die diesen diesen äh.
Einfluss da haben. Bill Marsek, den haben wir auch zum Beispiel der hat Fiel auch zu dem äh Finsbi,
analysiert. Äh mit dem werden wir da auch nochmal in Kontakt, als wir die den Teil geschrieben haben. Ja, schon ganz cool.
Haben wir noch was?
Das wird auf jeden Fall mal spannend. Dann habe ich hier noch einen einen Artikel gefunden äh,
Und zwar gibt es ein wurde ein FBI-Dokument veröffentlicht bei The Record ähm,
Welche, wo das FBI sich mal aufgeschrieben hat, von welchen äh verschlüsselten Messengern sie was äh bekommen können.
Und ähm,
Dabei sind Apple i-Message, Lion, Signal, Telegram, Threema, Weiber, WeChat, WhatsApp.
Und Wicka,
Die sind da jetzt irgendwie mit in dieser Tabelle ähm abgebildet und da drunter steht immer so, welche wo kommt das FBI legal dran? Also Inhalte und Metadaten.
Und äh schön ist da ähm bei den meisten Städten no message content.
Also bei Wiker WeChat, Weiber, Threema, Telegram, Signal,
gibt es keinen Message Content auf legalem Wege bei Laien, Apple i-Message und WhatsApp,
steht dran, Message Content limited. Ich vermute das Limited bedeutet quasi Message Content ab ihrem Sapina.
Ja, dass man irgendwie sagt, okay, wir holen uns das und dann kannst du ab dann äh diese Daten bekommen.
Sogar dabei, also.
Oder hier steht number da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob das jetzt heißt die letzten 25 Tage nur oder.
Wie sie wie sie das genau meinen. Dafür kann ich wahrscheinlich nicht genug.
So ähnlich würde ich das jetzt auch interpretieren. Also da ist halt auf jeden Fall ein entsprechender erforderlich. Ähm.
Und dann äh geht es halt über iCloud-Backups, ne?
Dann steht aber zum Beispiel hier genau, bei WhatsApp steht nämlich auch dran, if Target is using and iPhone and i cloud Backups are nabeld. I loud returns, may container WhatsApp-Dater
Trinksuite, message Content. Es ist äh eine sehr schöne äh Zusammenfassung.
Was die so äh was was sie da so an Daten bekommen bei ähm Signal ist es keine Nachrichteninhalte,
Datum und Uhrzeit, wann sich der Nutzer registriert hat oder die die Userin registriert hat,
und letztes Datum wann die Nutzerin sich dorthin verbunden hat. Datensparsam würde ich sagen. Ähm,
Bei Threema keine Nachrichteninhalte, der Hashtag der Telefonnummer und E-Mail-Adresse.
Wenn der Nutzer den gegeben hat. Man kann ja bei früh mal sagen, ich möchte über meine bekanntere Identity auffindbar sein. Pushtalken, wenn der Nutzerin einen Pushtalken äh den Push-Service nutzt, den Public Key.
Datum der ID Creation und Datum des letzten Logins, also auch äh die anderen Daten sind da jetzt nicht wirklich,
relevant, weil die Telefonnummer wissen sie wahrscheinlich eh schon von der äh von der C-Person, wenn sie die angegeben hat.
Ja, aber da kann man äh bei der Wahl des Messengers auf jeden Fall äh sehen, was man haben möchte und äh Telegram
no message contact und dann steht da no contact information provided, follow in Forcement,
Das.
Die Generelle legt uns doch am Arsch Regel bei Telegram. Das ist schon wirklich hardcore.
Ja, also das ist schon echt äh ja, es äh Hardcore, ja, muss man so sagen.
Na ja, bin mal gespannt, wie lange sie damit noch durchkommen irgendwie.
Da werden sie nicht lange mit nicht mehr so lange mit durchkommen. Also das wird das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das insbesondere die Europäische Union äh sich auch irgendwann nicht mehr gefallen lassen wird. Und da hatten wir hat er diese schöne Sendung.
Mit Max Hoppenstedt über äh Telegram. Ähm,
jetzt auch natürlich sagen muss. Der Film war jetzt wie steht man dazu, ne? Ist ja eigentlich auch schon ganz gut ein äh Messenger zu haben, der halt Privacy und,
ernst nimmt. Aber habe ich das richtig gelesen, dass Telegram jetzt ähm Werbung reinschaltet.
Äh geht das wohl langsam los mit der Monetarisierung.
Bezahlt werden.
Dann werden wir nochmal sehen, wie sich das entwickelt.
Deutschland hat ja auch einen Messenger.
Warte mal, bevor wir darauf noch kommen, ein ein Hinweis. Also was man hier sehr schön sieht, ist, dass äh bei Apple die offene Flanke wirklich diese iCloud Backup sind.
Und das ähm das ist ja auch schon seit längerem eine eine Diskussion,
was Apple eigentlich davon abhält, diese Backups komplett zu verschlüsseln,
Ne, also die ne, Frage ist, wer hat quasi den den Key zu diesem Backup? Und das ist ja auch eine Abwägung zwischen.
Einerseits eben diesem Aspekt. Ja, also was kann von mir an Daten, an privaten Daten letztlich tatsächlich angesehen und äh ermittelt werden?
Versus Komfort,
ne, weil die natürlich auch das Problem haben, dass irgendwie jeden Tag in äh Tausende Apple Stores Leute reingerannt kommen und irgendwie mit Heu äh verheultem Gesicht irgendwie nach ihren äh Fotos schreien.
Ihren Kindern, die sie auf ihrem Telefon hatten. Das Telefon ist aber jetzt gerade irgendwo äh abgesoffen und sie haben irgendwie ihr Passwort vergessen und was nicht alles.
Denen dann sozusagen noch die Möglichkeit zu geben, Zugriff zu erlangen. Das ist an der Stelle auch eine Entscheidung. Wenn du sagst so
Key ist weg ähm so dann dann ist er halt auch weg ne und,
Viele Leute haben einfach ein Problem mit Passwort-Vorhalten und so weiter. Das ist halt ein echtes Problem. Und ähm ich frage mich auch immer wieder,
wie Apple dazu eigentlich selber steht, ja ob sie nicht diese Lücke nochmal schließen wollen und den Leuten quasi eine Möglichkeit,
geben eine einfache Passwörter ähm zu behalten in irgendeiner Form physisch auf eine einfache Methode, das ist auch begreifend.
Oder nicht.
Na ja, Sie, also das ist ja gar nicht so schwer, das machen Sie ja, wenn du Fallwoll machst ja auch. Da aber also wenn jetzt beim Mac Fuldis Incription einschaltest,
Sagen sie dir, das ist hier der Key, den du brauchst, wenn du den nicht hast, wirst du nicht mehr in deine Daten kommen, ja, druckt dit jetzt aus, bestätige, dass du das gedruckt hast oder was auch immer, ja?
Und ähm,
bestätige, dass du dir das aufgeschrieben hast und dass du weißt, dass das irgendwie ein Problem ist, wenn du's nicht mehr hast und sollen wir's nicht für dich in die iCloud legen?
Ja und das ist natürlich das Häkchen will man nicht machen. Das Häkchen willst du nicht haben, weil das natürlich,
heißt ne auf das, was in der iCloud ist, können Behörden zugreifen und wenn sie darauf zugreifen können, können sie auch deinen Computer beschlagnahmen und zack haben sie die da,
äh
Mache ich den Haken.
Die kommen. Die Sache ist ja die, die Bullen kommen bei mir ja gar nicht mehr rein. Bei mir ist nämlich zwei G. So und.
Da hat er nicht geklebt.
Mal ehrlich, Omikrohn, wenn ich OmiCrohn den Rechner aufsetze und ich mache da auf Highway an, dann setze ich den scheiß Haken.
Ja klar. Ja weil O.
Du machst das? Nee, ich setze den Haken nicht.
Will einfach ist halt einfach Frage so äh an der Stelle und du musst es eine Risikoabschätzung ja.
Was, was, was, was, was fährt denn um mikron für dicke Dinger? Ja, wo hat sie denn irgendwie? Ja.
Wissen wir ja nicht. Das finden wir jetzt erst noch raus, was.
Klar, die ist auch so ein bisschen im Bitcoin unterwegs und so, aber ich meine deswegen kommen wir ja nicht gleich an den Pranger.
Du, wenn du Pech hast, dann macht Omi Krond dir einen great reset?
Für Bitcoin würde man erst in 30 Jahren an die Wand gestellt. Das das das erlebt ja eh nicht mehr.
Übrigens jetzt oh ähzwei G-Regelungen für den Einzelhandel das heißt wir lassen die Umgeimpften jetzt verhungern.
Ich glaube Supermärkte sind da schon doch eher ausgeschlossen.
Ach so, es ist kein Einzelhandel.
Ist dann äh wie heißt es so schön, ähm äh Orte der Versorgung, des täglichen Bedarfs ist äh nochmal eine andere Kategorie als Einzelhandel.
Siehst du, das ist das ist das, was ich hier immer so halb gehangene Sachen, ja? Stellt dir jetzt einfach mal zu sagen, so zack Leute, zwei G. Teilweise wäre ich ja froh, wenn ich irgendwo zwei G hätte im Supermarkt. Der ist ja meistens Funkloch, aber ähm.
In dem Bereich sind jetzt auch alle Witze gemacht schon.
Zwei Gehegelung im.
Aber um das Thema äh abzuschließen ähm.
Genau, IKEA-Backups wollt ihr nicht haben, Kies gehören niemals zu jemand anders, es sei denn ihr seid Omikron und habt nix zu verbergen.
Backup machen, weil iCloud-Backup hat schon Vorteile. Definitiv. Na gut. Next.
Gut,
Wen haben wir? Äh genau hier äh das ist eigentlich nur noch so ein kleiner Lacher am Rande. Hm das BMI hat jetzt eine Rüge bekommen für.
Weil sie haben trotz mehrfacher Aufforderung des Bundesrechnungshofes nie eine Erfolgskontrolle für De-Mail durchgeführt,
und äh deswegen bekommen sie jetzt eine äh Rüge
äh ganzen Kapitel im Jahresbericht des Bundesrechnungshofes, in dem sie sagen, das war ja mal geplant als sichere, vertrauliche und nachweisbare Kommunikation im Internet. Äh
ist aber letztendlich E-Mail und aber nicht mit E-Mail koopatible und hat deswegen auch nie, weil's jemand wirklich genutzt, ja.
Und äh insgesamt wurden dreistellig Millionen da drin versenkt und jetzt sagt der ähm.
Bundesrechnungshof, das BMI ist gescheitert. Als elektronisches Pendant zur Briefpost in der Bundesverwaltung zu etablieren
äh zwischen 2011 und 2020 hat das BMI etwa sechseinhalb Millionen Euro dafür ausgegeben und äh.
Das BMI ging davon aus, dass in der Bundesverwaltung zwischen 2016 und 2019 etwa 6 Millionen D-Mails verschickt würden
Und er hoffte sich damit, dreieinhalb Millionen Euro Einsparung gegenüber der Briefpost. Das ist aber nicht passiert.
Laut dem Bericht hatten die Bundesbehörden im Jahr zwanzig16,
nur 250 D-Milz empfangen und weniger als 90 selbst Versand.
Im ganzen Jahr. Also ich habe ja immer gesagt, dass ich von den Serverbetreibern von den hohen Einstelligen äh,
von den hohen einstelligen Anzahl an dem er jetzt pro Tag höre
äh und ja, das das äh hat sich dann bestätigt, ja. Also wenn man das jetzt mal umrechnet auf äh was das Gesamtprojekt gekostet hat, würde ich jetzt empfehlen, aus den versendeten Demails, aus den wenigen versendeten De-Mails NFTs zu machen.
Weil die haben auf jeden Fall mehrere Millionen gekostet pro Nachricht. Das ist eigentlich ganz lustig.
Ja okay und dann gibt's noch eine nicht so lustige äh Nachricht.
Warte mal, das Bundesinnenministerium hat 6,5 Millionen Euro ausgegeben. Das war sozusagen die Staatskosten und die dreistelligen äh Millionen, die insgesamt investiert wollen.
Die die Betreiber.
Was die Betreiber gemacht haben. Das heißt, sie haben irgendwie Minus so, aber allein die Staatsinvestitionen, also die Staatsinvestitionen sind dann bei 6,5 Millionen.
Das ist jetzt nur das BMI. Ich bin bin mir nicht sicher, ob da auch äh äh berücksichtigt ist, dass ähm,
dass dass die ähm was jetzt einzelne Behörden für Kosten hatten. Da das ist jetzt nur das BMI, dem sie sagen, ey hier, ihr hättet das mal prüfen müssen, ja?
Also wenn man nur mal die Ausgaben vom BMI nimmt, ja und es sind 6000 E-Mails mit diesem ganzen System überhaupt verschickt wurden. Sechstausend.
Du rechnest das mal auf diese 6, nur auf diese 6,5 Millionen um. Dann kommst du sozusagen auf einen gerufenen Preis von über tausend Euro pro E-Mail.
Zu jeder einzelnen Nachricht vom Notar beglaubigen lassen können und als.
Telekom irgendwie über übermitteln so. Wer alles voll drin gewesen.
Ich sage, mach NFTs draus, das ist die teuerste Kommunikation, die du je hattest.
Kohle wieder rein da am Ende. Wir sollten die ganze Bundesregierung als NFT verkaufen, die Alte irgendwie.
Um den geringeren Nutzungszahlen entgegenzuwirken, hätte das BM
I gemeinsam mit den Behörden des Bundes die Ursachen hier vermitteln müssen, welche Rolle Däne bei der Umsetzung des Online-Zugangsgesetzes spielen wird, ist weiterhin offen. Der Bundesrechnungshof bezweifelt, dass De-Mail wirtschaftlich ist.
Das ist gut, dass wir das.
Ja, wie du wie du schon vor vielen Jahren so trefflich festgestellt hast, Bullshit made in Germany. Das war aber.
Ja, ist halt leider.
Ausgesprochen treffender Titel für deinen Vortrag.
Hey, ist auch mein Vortrag mit dem besten Logo. Hier noch diesen kackenden Hund dazu.
Okay Julia ähm Reeder war ja vor einigen Wochen zuletzt bei uns und hat ähm über diesen,
nein, Fall gesprochen.
Wo also Sony Music Deutschland sagt, ey hier, ihr habt einen DNS-Sybisol und ihr müsst jetzt äh äh bitte.
Ähm diesen äh,
diesen spezifischen Domänennamen nicht mehr auflösen. Da haben wir eine äh einstweilige Verfügung erwirkt vom äh,
Amtgericht Hamburg oder wo die die,
und wurde die einstweilige her hatten, weiß ich nicht genau. Also eventuell warte mal, wenn du dich gegen eine einstweilige Wehrst, geht das an das gleiche Gericht. Ja, erstmal, ne
meine schon. Also Landgericht Hamburg äh und die haben den Widerspruch gegen diese einstweilige erhoben und das,
hat diesen Widerspruch, hat das Landgericht Hamburg jetzt,
abgelehnt, ne? Also einstweilige Verfügung heißt, wir haben hier ein so unmittelbares Interesse, dass wir vom Gericht quasi ein Vorurteil ähm,
äh eben anfertigen lassen, die einstweilige Verfügung. Das Gericht verfügt einstweilig die Sperrung.
Und das Gericht tut das in dem Vertrauen, dass wir hier schon alles,
vorgetragen haben und das sind Dringlichkeitsanspruch entsteht. B steht, weil sonst irgendwie größerer Schaden noch
stattfindet, ja und dann wird diese einstweilige Verfügung eben erlassen und jetzt hat dann Quad Nein gesagt, nein, wir wehren uns gegen diese Verfügung und da hat jetzt jetzt hat bringen unsere Gründe vor und da hat das Landgericht Hamburg jetzt gesagt, so nö
Wir halten diese Verfügung.
Aufrecht und damit ist das jetzt auch ein Urteil, ja? Und äh Quad Nein hat jetzt oder Quat Nein hat jetzt halt gesagt direkt unmittelbar nach der Urteilsverkündung, dass sie in die nächste Instanz gehen werden.
Und äh eben sich als gemeinnützige Stiftung, die einen DNS-Server unterhält, nun äh gegen äh Sony Music Entertainment weiter äh zur Wehr setzt.
Das ist ein ähm äh nicht also erst mal kein besonders schönes Urteil, aber auch in Hamburg leider nicht anders zu erwarten und Courtney hat eben darauf geantwortet,
korrekt. Wir haben den Feier hier mit Julia ausführlich besprochen. Nein, ist an keinem Schritt, der behaupteten Urheberrechtsverletzung auch nur indirekt beteiligt. Ja, auf unseren Servern befinden sich keine Urheberrechtsverletzenden Daten. Wir haben keinerlei Geschäfts,
Beziehung zu der inkriminierten Seite. Vielmehr äh sollen wir jetzt hier auf Zuruf einer,
als Rechtinhaber auftretenden Partei,
Telefonbucheintrag löschen von irgendjemand anders. Ja und äh ja ich denke das Content eigentlich auf der richtigen Seite und deswegen wird dieser Fall ja auch äh von uns äh und auch von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte,
mit entsprechender äh äh Vehemenz verfolgt und äh berichtet.
Ja, also da erst mal leider quasi die erste ähm,
Die erste aber auch leider zu erwartende Niederlage. Weil das Landgericht Hamburg ist eben auch schon in diesem Bereich bekannt. Das wählt man ja nicht ohne Grund.
Ja das hatten wir ja schon paar Mal.
Ja, was hätten wir noch an Themen? Es gab einen äh also ich wäre zuerst mal am Ende. Es gibt wir müssen mal nächste Woche dann über das TT DSG sprechen.
Kompliziert ist. Telekommunikations- und Telemediendienste, Datenschutzgesetz, das ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Das habe ich für diese Sendung nicht mehr geschafft.
Ähm noch einiges auf der Liste.
Ja und auch wir hatten auf der Liste ja einen Bonustrack, den hast du jetzt für UKW genommen, ne.
Du als ihn auf der Liste. Aber äh.
Auf der Liste gehabt, ja.
Haben ja einen Bonus-Trick.
Wir haben einen anderen Bundestreck, aber ich will nur ich will zumindest noch kurz darauf hinweisen, für diejenigen, die UKW nicht hören, in den unter Bonustrack ist ist ein alternativer Bonustrack. Nochmal,
Wir haben quasi anderthalb Bonus. Da hinten wir haben Bonustrack zum Bonustrack für euch. Das gibt's auch nur bei uns.
Irre, irre,
Ja. So jetzt haben wir euch aber genug äh mit positiven Nachrichten genervt. Es hat schon wieder alles so den Anflug von Optimismus, ne? So ja die Bösen Spionageunternehmen werden verklagt und,
Koalitionsverträge versprechen uns blühende Landschaften. Na ja. Na ja.
So, wenn du so ein kurzer Moment weihnachtlicher Vorfreude vor vorm vorm vorm Lock.
Genau. Gut Leute, das war's äh für diese Woche und ähm wir hören uns bald wieder. Und sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Ciao ciao.